ALL RIGHT, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AGAIN, WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT YOU
ARE HERE WITH US. AT THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE FOR MARCH 20TH
2024. I DON'T KNOW WHERE THIS
MONTH IS GOING. WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT EACH OF YOU ARE HERE TODAY
WE WANT TO WELCOME OUR MADAM
VICE CHAIR. AND OF COURSE, UH,
EACH OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BEFORE WE BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MADAM
SECRETARY. GOOD AFTERNOON. IT IS
GOOD TO SEE YOU. IF YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MAGUIRE. HERE.
MAGUIRE HERE, GROVE. GROVE HERE,
EGM. EDMUND HERE, JONES. I AM
HERE. JONES HERE. LAIRD LAIRD.
HERE COR, THANK YOU. SO MUCH
BETTER SECRETARY. QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED. UH, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WHO ARE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING ONLINE. IT IS A BUSY
DAY HERE IN CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. WE'LL HAVE SENATOR
EGMOND AND LEADER JONES, WHO
WILL NEED TO ATTEND OTHER
COMMITTEE HEARINGS. WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO TODAY IS AS WE MOVE
THROUGH EACH OF OUR POTENTIAL
APPOINTEES WHO ARE REQUIRED TO
APPEAR TO PUT THOSE THE ITEMS ON
CALL. IF THEY ARE NOT BACK, AND
THEN WE'LL ADD ON EACH OF THOSE
SENATORS AS THEY COME BACK AFTER
THEY VOTE IN THEIR OTHER
COMMITTEES, AND I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO MISS EDMAN
AND MR JONES FOR THE WORK AS
THEY'RE JUGGLING A LOT ON THEIR
PLATE TODAY, SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH, UM, BEFORE WE BRING UP OUR
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS POTENTIAL
APPOINTEES BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY, WE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE CARE OF SOME
HOUSEKEEPING AND COMMITTEE
BUSINESS IF THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
UH, IT WILL TAKE US JUST A FEW
MINUTES. IF THERE ARE NÓ
OBJECTIONS, I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE UP UNDER NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR AND GOVERNOR APPOINTEES.
ITEMS TWO EG ITEMS TWO E THROUGH
G DO ANY MEMBERS WISH TO
SEPARATE THE VOTES? NÓ SIR.
STILL MOVED. THE VICE CHAIR HAS
MADE A MOTION UNDER GOVERNOR
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR ITEMS. TWO EG. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. MADAM SENATOR, LET'S
CALL THE ROLL. MCGUIRE MAGUIRE I
, GROVE GROVE. I EG EG I JONES.
I JONES I LAIRD THIRD, I 5 TO 0
THAT IS A 5 TO 0 VOTE. THOSE
APPOINTEES WILL BE HEADING TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO BILL
REFERRALS. WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE UP ITEM THREE REFERENCE
OF BILLS TO COMMITTEES WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MADAM VICE CHAIR.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
I, GROVE GROVE I EGM EGM. I
JONES JONES. I LAIRD LAIRD, I 5
TO 0 HOT, DEAR. THAT IS A 50
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
COMMITTEE, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
UP FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGEMENT. THIS
IS OUR FINAL ITEM BEFORE WE JUMP
BACK TO GOVERNOR APPOINTEES. WE
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TAKE UP
ITEMS. FOUR THROUGH 744 THROUGH
SEVEN FOR FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS.
LET'S ENTERTAIN A MOTION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ADAM. VICE CHAIR,
MADAM VICE CHAIR. UH, MOVES
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? MCGUIRE? GROVE. I EG
EG I JONES JONES, I LAIRD LAIRD,
I 5 TO 0. THAT IS 5 TO 0 VOTE
BIPARTISAN. LOOK AT THAT. WE'RE
MOVING. ALL RIGHT. WE TOLD YOU
THAT IT WAS GONNA BE QUICK.
WE'RE COMING NOW INTO DOING A
JUMP BACK TO ITEM NUMBER ONE, A
GOVERNOR APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO
APPEAR AND AGAIN. WE'LL HAVE
FOLKS COMING IN AND OUT OF
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR UNDERSTANDING HERE
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO ADVANCE TWO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. THIS IS ITEMS ONE A AND
ONE B. TODAY'S CALENDAR. THE
APPOINTMENTS WOULD BE RAJI BAR
AND MARK GIRARDI AS MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
BOARD OF TRUSTEES. WE ARE GOING
TO INVITE BOTH UP, PLEASE
WELCOME. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE
WOULD LIKE TO LAY OUT A FORMAT
IF THAT'S ALL RIGHT TO EACH OF
THE TRUSTEES, WE ARE GOING TO
HEAR FROM EACH OF YOU. EACH OF
YOU HAVE ABOUT A MINUTE OR TWO
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE OPENING
TESTIMONY TO THE COMMITTEE. WE
ARE GOING TO OPEN IT UP FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO
ASK QUESTIONS, ADVANCE ANY
COMMENTS THAT THEY MAY HAVE IN
YOUR OPENING. WE HOPE THAT YOU
ARE ABLE TO WELCOME YOUR GUESTS
ACKNOWLEDGE ANY FAMILY OR
FRIENDS THAT ARE WITH YOU, AND
WE WANT TO WELCOME THEM TO
TODAY'S COMMITTEE. IT WILL BE
KEEPING TIME ONCE YOU GET CLOSE
TO THAT TWO MINUTES, NOT AT ALL
TRYING PUSHY OR RUDE OR GIVE A
TIME AS COMING UP AND JUST WANNA
STATE. WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL. UH
FOR YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU. SO
MUCH FOR APPEARING. UH, MADAM
TRUSTEE. WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH YOU. PLEASE. WE WELCOME YOU
TO COMMITTEE. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU SO MUCH. IT'S
WONDERFUL TO BE HERE. UH, FIRST
LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY GUEST, MY
DAUGHTER, MISS AMANI BAR, A
SOPHOMORE FROM LIBERTY HIGH
SCHOOL IN BAKERSFIELD. UM
HONORED TO HAVE HER HERE WITH ME
AND I'M HONORED TO BE HERE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MYSELF. I'M A
FIRST GENERATION PUNJABI, SIKH
AMERICAN. MY PARENTS IMMIGRATED
TO THIS COUNTRY BACK IN THE
EARLY SIXTIES, AND THEY STARTED
THEIR LIFE HERE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AS FARM WORKERS AND I
GREW UP IN FARM LABOR CAMPS
UNTIL MY DAD DECIDED TO MOVE US
TO THE BIG CITY OF BAKERSVILLE
FOR MORE OPPORTUNITY, AND, UH,
WENT TO BAKERSFIELD WENT TO
JUNIOR HIGH HIGH SCHOOL. DOUBLE
ALUMNI FROM THE èC S¼ U. I HAVE
A BACHELORS IN BIOLOGY AND A
MASTERS IN HEALTHCARE FROM èC
S¼ U BAKERSFIELD. I WORKED AS A
CHEMIST FOR A WHILE AND THEN IN
HEALTH CARE, AND ONE DAY I GOT A
GREAT CALL FROM MY DAD AND SAID
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE NOT TOO
HAPPY IN WHAT YOU'RE DOING. YOU
WANT TO BUSINESS IN ARVIN AND I
DID. I OPENED A SUBWAY FRANCHISE
IN ARVIN. AND THAT WAS 23 YEARS
AGO, AND I DECIDED TO JOIN MY
DAD IN BUSINESS. AND TODAY WE
EMPLOY OVER 600 PEOPLE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. WE HAVE
CONSTRUCTION, RETAIL DEVELOPMENT
AND SO MANY OTHER THINGS, BUT
THE POINT OF HONOR. ME IS THAT
IN MY CULTURE, DAUGHTERS DON'T
USUALLY WORK WITH A FAMILY
BUSINESS AND MY DAD WAS A BIG
VISIONARY, AND I'M HAPPY TO SAY
THAT I'M ABLE TO GROW A BUSINESS
WITH MY FATHER. UM, ALSO DURING
THAT TIME, I WAS ASKED TO RUN
FOR CITY COUNCIL AND I'M HONORED
TO BE THE FIRST èC COLEMAN EVER
ELECTED TO A CITY COUNCIL SEAT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
2006, AND EVENTUALLY, UM, A FEW
YEARS OF THAT, I DECIDED TO STEP
AWAY FROM THAT AND FOCUS ON
BUSINESS AND FAMILY. AND IT WAS
A GREAT DECISION. BUT AS YOU ALL
KNOW, YOU GET A PHONE CALL, AND
I GOT A CALL MANY YEARS AGO AND
ASKED ME TO SERVE ON VARIOUS
DIFFERENT BOARDS FOR THE STATE,
AND I WAS HONORED TO DO SO FROM
THE FAIR BOARD TO THE WATER
BOARD. AND NOW TO THIS
APPOINTMENT, WHICH IS REALLY
AMAZING, CAUSE IF CONFIRMED, I'D
BE THE FIRST SIKH EVER TO SERVE
ON THE èC S¼ U BOARD OF
TRUSTEES. SOMETHING I'M VERY
PROUD OF. I ALSO HAVE A
NONPROFIT UH, THE SEQUELS
ASSOCIATION, WHICH I FORMED,
WHICH HELPS YOUNG WOMEN. UM IN
MY CULTURE COMMUNITY. IT'S VERY
PATRIARCHAL COMMUNITY BUT
BASICALLY HELPS THEM, UH,
ADVANCE IN LIFE. WE HAVE A FIRST
OF ITS KIND PHONE LINE THAT'S
BILINGUAL, PUNJABI AND ENGLISH
TO HELP WITH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SO MANY OTHER ISSUES, AND WE
RAISED MONEY FOR SCHOLARSHIPS
FOR KIDS TO GO TO COLLEGE.
ESPECIALLY THE èC S¼ U, UM AND
I WOULD NOT BE SITTING HERE FOR
IT WAS NOT FOR THE èC S¼ U. SO
I I'M A VERY, UM, HONORED FOR
THAT. AND UM I WANNA SAY THAT,
UH THE èC S¼ U S¼ OPEN DOORS
FOR ME AND I LOVE TO SAY THAT I
AM THE PROMISE OF THE èC S¼ U
ACTUALLY SITTING IN FRONT OF
YOU. AND I WAS LUCKY TO GO TO
èC S¼ U BECAUSE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE FINANCIAL FREEDOM AND
MAKE DECISIONS FOR MYSELF THAT
I, QUITE FRANKLY WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO MAKE IF I DIDN'T HAVE MY
EDUCATION, SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY, AND I
ACTUALLY CHERISH MY ROLE AS A
TRUSTEE. IT'S A RESPONSIBILITY.
I DON'T TAKE LIGHTLY. AND I'M UM
, HAPPY TO SAY THAT, UH, USUALLY
IN ROOMS. I WAS ALWAYS ONE OF
MANY BUT ONE BUT TODAY THERE'S
TWO CAUSE MY DAUGHTER'S HERE
TODAY, SO IT'S PRETTY AMAZING.
SO THANK YOU. I'M SORRY, MR
CHAIR, MADAM VICE CHAIR IN YOUR
FAVORITE SENATOR IS SHANNON
GROVE FROM KERN COUNTY AND
BAKERSFIELD AND ARVIN AND
ACTUALLY EXCUSE ME. I WANTED TO
SAY HELLO TO EACH OF YOU, BUT,
OF COURSE, SHANNON, UM IS FROM
CORRECTING THE RECORD JUST
CORRECTING THE RECORD HOMETOWN.
ARVIN CALIFORNIA, KERN COUNTY.
SO UH, MADAM VICE CHAIR IS
BREAKING OUT THE TWO BY FAR
ALREADY. SO HERE WE GO. I LIKE
IT, MAN. TRUSTY THANK YOU. REAL
CALIFORNIA SUCCESS STORY. A
REALLY GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
HERE. THANK YOU. SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SERVICE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE COMMITTEE,
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE TURNING
IN. CIRCULAR DUTY IS WONDERFUL
TO SEE YOU. AND IT'S ALSO GOOD
TO SEE YOU NOT IN A DISASTER
ZONE AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS, SIR
. THANKS, MR CHAIR. YES WELL,
SOME DAYS HERE EARLY SO EARLY.
WELL IT'S ALWAYS WONDERFUL TO
FOLLOW RAJI HES SUCH A SUPERSTAR
. AND DON'T ASK ME WHO MY
FAVORITE SENATOR IS BECAUSE
YOU'RE YOU'RE ALL THERE, GZ. I
POINTS OUT RIGHT FROM THE GET
GO, UM ON THAT, UM, ANYWAY, IT'S
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU ALL TODAY
AND, OF COURSE TO SEE MANY LONG
TIME. COLLEAGUES UM, HONORED TO
SPEAK BEFORE YOU TODAY ABOUT MY
CONFIRMATION FOR CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY TRUSTEE. I'M
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR
AND FOR, UH, FOR YOU KNOW THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE IN THIS
CRITICAL ROLE AND CONTRIBUTE TO
CONTINUED SUCCESS OF THE
EXCELLENCE OF THE èC S¼ U AS
MOST OF YOU KNOW, I RECENTLY
RETIRED AFTER A DECADE OF
SERVING AS AGENCY SECRETARY AND
DIRECTOR AT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES, A
TIME WHEN OUR STATE FACED
COUNTLESS COMPLEX CHALLENGES IN
SEVERAL CATASTROPHIC DISASTERS.
SHORTLY AFTER RETIREMENT.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM APPOINTED ME AS
A TRUSTEE TO BRING MY EXPERIENCE
AND PERSPECTIVE TO THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES THROUGHOUT MY CAREER IN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND PUBLIC
SERVICE. I'VE HAVE DEDICATED TO
EQUITABLY SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ENSURING THE
SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. I BELIEVE THAT MY
EXPERTISE AND EXPERIENCE IN
CRISIS AND SECURITY MANAGEMENT,
STRATEGIC PLANNING AND
COLLABORATION COLLABORATION MAKE
ME WELL SUITED TO HELP GUIDE THE
èC S¼ U IN ADDRESSING THE
CURRENT AND FUTURE CHALLENGES
AND OPPORTUNITIES FACING HIGHER
EDUCATION IN OUR STATE. THIS
OPPORTUNITY IS PARTICULARLY
SPECIAL TO ME BORN IN THE BAY
AREA. UH, GROWING UP IN
CALIFORNIA COMING FROM POST
DEPRESSION ERA WORKING CLASS
PARENTS WHO INSTILLED THE VALUES
OF FAMILY, HARD WORK, COMMUNITY
SERVICE AND THE IMPORTANCE OF AN
EDUCATION. I WAS THE FIRST
GENERATION TO OBTAIN A FOURYEAR
COLLEGE DEGREE GRADUATING FROM
UC DAVIS. UH, AN EXPERIENCE THAT
REINFORCED IN ME THE VALUE AND
IMPORTANCE OF A COLLEGE
EDUCATION AND HELP ME SHAPE. UH,
AN ADVANCE MY ENTIRE CAREER. I'M
A PARTICULARLY ATTRACTED TO THE
MISSION AND THE VALUES OF THE
èC S¼ U, FOSTERING DIVERSITY,
EQUITY AND INCLUSION AND
PROMOTING ACADEMIC EXCELLENCE
AND STUDENT SUCCESS. I WAS ABLE
TO OBSERVE THIS FIRST HAND AS MY
DAUGHTER RECEIVED AN OUTSTANDING
EDUCATION THAT PREPARED HER FOR
SUCCESSFUL. ENTERING THE
WORKFORCE, GRADUATING FROM CAL
STATE SAN MARCOS WITH A DEGREE
IN COMMUNICATION. I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
MY FELLOW TRUSTEES. FACULTY
STAFF STUDENTS, THE COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND ALL OF
YOU. TO ADVANCE THE GOALS OF THE
èC S¼ U AND TO ENSURE THAT IT
CONTINUES TO BE THE DRIVER OF
SOCIAL MOBILITY, ECONOMIC
SUCCESS AND A BEACON OF
OPPORTUNITY AND INNOVATION FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS SAY THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERING CONSIDERATION MY
NOMINATION FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY. THANKS
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. TRES, YOU
VERY GRATEFUL. APPRECIATE BOTH
OF YOU FOR BEING HERE. WE ARE
GOING TO OPEN IT UP TO
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS FROM THE
RULES COMMITTEE, MADAM VICE
CHAIR. WOULD YOU LIKE TO KICK
THIS OFF, PLEASE? THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR. I HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY THAT I KNOW
BOTH OF YOU PERSONALLY, I'VE
WORKED WITH YOU ON THE CREEK
FIRE ON THE ESC. ESCAR ESQUIRE
FIRE. I'VE WORKED WITH YOU,
ERSKINE. FIRE UM UH, YOU ARE OUT
OF THE BOX THINKER, A PROBLEM
SOLVER AND I WOULD NEVER IN A
MILLION YEARS. VOTE NÓ ON A
CONFIRMATION, UH, THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN APPOINTED TO AND I
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK AND
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS VENTURE. ON THE OTHER
HAND. NÓ I HAVE THE SAME
COMMENTS ABOUT YOU, RAJI, YOU
ARE ONE OF OUR COMMUNITY LEADERS
. YOU GO OUT OF YOUR WAY TO
ELEVATE THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY. UM
YOU ARE A PRODUCT OF THE èC S¼
U SYSTEM AND TO HAVE A MONEY
HERE. THAT IS JUST AMAZING THAT
SHE WILL ONE DAY FOLLOW IN HER
MOTHER'S FOOTSTEPS AND, UM AND
WHAT YOU BRING AND HAVE BROUGHT
TO THE ELEVATION OF THE SIKH
COMMUNITY AND WOMEN IN THE SIKH
COMMUNITY FOR CULTURALLY AND
ADVANCING THAT CULTURE AND AGAIN
A CITY COUNCIL BUT ALSO ANOTHER
CITY. WILL SEEK MEMBER JUST GOT
ELECTED. SO YOU ARE MAKING
HEADWAY. AND UM, I WOULD, UH UH,
NEVER VOTE AGAINST YOU EITHER. I
WOULD SUPPORT YOU ON ANY
CONFIRMATION THAT YOU HAVE.
BESIDES YOUR DAD WOULD YELL AT
ME. I'M TEASING. HE WOULDN'T. HE
LOVES ME TOO. SO I AM ALL IN FOR
BOTH OF THEM. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT ADVICE. VERY GRATEFUL.
PLEASE MR LAIR. OH, JEEZ. THAT
JUST OPENED SO MANY THINGS. II I
INVITE ME WHEN YOU DAD YELLS AT
HER. I WANT TO BE THERE. AND NOW
THAT YOU BOTH HAVE BLANK CHECKS
THAT SHE WOULD VOTE FOR YOU FOR
ANY SINGLE CONFIRMATION. YOU
SHOULD BOTH SEEK A STATEWIDE
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICE OR DO
SOMETHING BECAUSE, UH, SHE SHE
HAS LOCKED IN. WELL LET ME THANK
BOTH OF YOU FOR THE TIME TO MEET
THIS MORNING. I REALLY
APPRECIATED OUR CONVERSATION.
AND OBVIOUSLY I. I SERVED IN THE
CABINET. A MARK AND IT IS HARD
TO SAY YOU HAVE FOND MEMORIES
ABOUT DISASTERS, BUT I ALWAYS
HAVE FOND MEMORIES OF US WORKING
TOGETHER AS DAMS WHERE OVER
FLOWING AND TOWNS WERE BURNING
DOWN AND THINGS WERE WERE
HAPPENING. I THINK I'D LIKE TO
ASK ABOUT A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT IN OUR
MEETING, AND THE FIRST ONE IS,
IS THAT UM, THERE HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED COMPACTS FOR THE AND
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM,
AND, UH, THE PROPOSAL THIS YEAR
IS THAT THE 5% THAT WOULD COME
TO èC S¼ U THIS YEAR WOULD BE
DEFERRED TO NEXT YEAR, WHICH
ACTUALLY WOULD MAKE 10% DUE TO
èC, S¼, U AND UC NEXT YEAR,
WHICH COULD BE A STRETCH. UH IF
WE ARE IN ANOTHER SUBSTANTIAL
BUDGET DEFICIT NEXT YEAR, SO I
THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE GOOD.
TALKING ABOUT YOUR VISION OF
HAVING THE FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE BUDGET AND
HOW EACH OF YOU ARE GOING TO
FACE A SORT OF HAVING BE ON THE
TRUSTEES AT THE TIME OF, UH UH,
A DIFFICULT BUDGET TIME AND
MAYBE WE'LL START WITH WITH
DIRECTOR GILARD LCI. WELL,
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION. I MEAN,
CERTAINLY. AS A TRUSTEE. OUR
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY IS
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO ENSURE FOR
THE SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM AND THE
ABILITY TO, UH, HAVE ALL THE
PROGRAMS WE HAVE DELIVERED
EFFECTIVELY. UM WE UNDERSTAND
AND APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR
FOR, UM, THE, UH, COMPACT AND,
UH, YOU KNOW, THIS YEAR WITH THE
DEFERRAL, UM, YOU KNOW, IT'S
JUST IT'S SOMETHING WE
UNDERSTAND AS A BUDGET. UM UH,
CHALLENGE FOR THE STATE. AS A
RESULT, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
CONSIDERED THAT. AT THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES. WE UM, ARE CONSTANTLY
REVIEWING THE VARIOUS I GUESS
YOU WOULD SAY SCENARIOS THAT ARE
GOING TO COME AT US WITH REGARDS
TO POTENTIAL BUDGET CUTS AND YOU
KNOW, WE ARE. I THINK WE ARE
ABLE TO NAVIGATE THAT THROUGH
THIS YEAR. UM IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE TO
ASSESS. UM IF IT GOES INTO THE
NEXT GO AROUND, I IT'S GONNA BE
TOUGHER. AND IT IT IS GONNA HAVE
TO REQUIRE THE TRUSTEES OF
HAVING TO MAKE TOUGHER DECISIONS
, BUT IN THE CONTEXT THAT WE
WANT TO MAINTAIN THE GREAT
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE THAT CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY PRESENTS, SO I
THINK THAT, UM YOU KNOW, WE ARE,
UM, LIKE MOST OF GOVERNMENT, UM,
NAVIGATING THROUGH THIS, AND IT
IS SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE TAKING AS AND PLANNING FOR
ACCORDINGLY. THANK YOU. I TRUST
YOU BAR. AH I AGREE WITH THE I
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY FELLOW
TRUSTEE. UM, OBVIOUSLY, UH, IT'S
A GREAT TIME WHEN THERE'S TONS
OF MONEY AND YOU CAN DO
EVERYTHING YOU WANNA DO. UH, I
WOULD ECHO HIS COMMENTS THAT
THIS YEAR WE ARE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT WE'LL BE OK. WE'LL TRY TO
MAKE THINGS WORK THIS YEAR, BUT
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT
YEARS TO COME. WE HAVE TO MAKE
SOME TOUGH DECISIONS. UH, WE
HAVE TO REAL REALLOCATE THINGS.
UM PRIORITIZE SITUATE. YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING. AND, UM UH, BUT
WE'RE GONNA DO WHAT'S IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF OUR STUDENTS,
BUT, UM AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO SIT DOWN WITH OUR FINANCE
TEAM AND ALL THE Tð S¼ U, UH,
PRESIDENTS AND ASK WHAT'S A
PRIORITY AT EACH CAMPUS, AND,
UH, WITHOUT REPEATING EVERYTHING
TRUSTED YOU A LITTLE, BCI SAID.
THAT'S HOW IT'S GONNA BE FOR US.
IT'S GOING TO BE A TOUGH TIME,
BUT, UH WE'RE GONNA GET THROUGH
IT. AND AS I MENTIONED THIS
MORNING, THE LEGISLATURE TRIED
TWO YEARS AGO TO GIVE MORE MONEY
THAN THE COMPACT REQUIRED
PARTICULARLY TO èC S¼ U BECAUSE
OF CERTAIN LABOR AGREEMENTS TO
TRY TO HELP èC S¼ U NAVIGATE
THAT AND THAT IS STILL OUT THERE
. SO THAT'S SOMETHING I KNOW.
WE'RE VERY CONSCIOUS OF. THEN
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT,
AND THAT IS WE TALKED ABOUT HOW
FORTUNATE YOU ARE THAT YOU
WEREN'T ONE OF THE FOUR
TRUSTEES. WE HAD TO CONFIRM A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AFTER THE
PREVIOUS CHANCELLOR RESIGNED AND
HAS BEEN A SYSTEM WIDE ISSUE
OVER TITLE IX AND CERTAIN ISSUES
REGARDING SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
I WAS GOING TO ASK UH, HOW YOU
TAKE YOUR RESPONSIBILITY AS A
TRUSTEE ON THAT ISSUE, AND MAYBE
WE'LL START IN IN REVERSE THIS
TIME. WELL AT THE èC S¼ U, WE
TAKE IT VERY SERIOUSLY. UH, THE
REPORT FROM COS AND O'CONNOR AND
THE STATE AUDITORS REPORT. UH
IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY FOR US, UH, TITLE
NINE IS A TOP OF MIND. WE'VE
ALREADY WENT AHEAD AND BEGAN THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COS AND A
CORNER RECOMMENDED WERE ALREADY
IMPLEMENTING THEM. WE'VE HIRED A
VICE CHANCELLOR. UH, FOR THE
CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT. UH, WE
ARE YOU KNOW, SETTING BENCHMARKS
FOR EVERY TWO MONTHS TO SEE
WHERE WE ARE ON THE PROCESS.
IT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT NOBODY
ON THAT TRUSTEE BOARD TAKES
LIGHTLY AT ALL. WE WANT EVERYONE
TO FEEL SAFE IN THE WORKPLACE.
WE WANT STUDENTS, FACULTY STAFF,
EVERYONE TO FEEL SAFE. WE WANT A
WAY THAT FOLKS HAVE A WAY TO
REPORT SITUATIONS THAT ARE
HAPPENING. AND I KNOW BEFORE WE
CAME IN THE èC S¼ U S¼ ROLE WAS
MORE OF AN ADVISORY NOW ARE NOW
WE ARE MORE OF OVERSIGHT, AND WE
WE'RE GONNA BE MORE INVOLVED,
AND THAT'S JUST THERE'S NÓ. THAT
THIS IS TOP PRIORITY FOR US, AND
I THINK BY HIRING OUR VICE
CHANCELLOR NOW, UM AND FOR THE
FOR THE OFFICE AND THEN JUST
GETTING EVERY EVERY CAMPUS ON
BOARD IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
SURE THIS IS IMPLEMENTED. I KNOW
THIS MORNING. WE ALSO TALKED
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
PROGRAMS IN PLACE. WHETHER IT'S
A CAMPAIGN THAT TALKS ABOUT YOU
SEE SOMETHING SAY SOMETHING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT STUDENTS ARE
AWARE THIS IS OUT THERE AND MAKE
SURE THAT FACULTY THAT IS WHERE
THIS IS OUT THERE, SO IT DOESN'T
JUST GO BY. WE HAVE A MEETING
BEHIND SOME CLOSED DOORS. THE
STUDENTS DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING. I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO KEEP THAT, UH,
DIALOG ABOUT TITLE NINE AND
SEXUAL HARASSMENT GOING SO THAT
EVERYONE'S AWARE ON CAMPUS.
THANK YOU ANYTHING TO ADD? UH
UH. IF YOU START TALKING IF I
CAN MAKE IT. COME ON, OK, GREAT.
UH, TECHNOLOGY, YOU KNOW, UM
WELL, I WOULD JUST TELL YOU THAT
AND SINCE I'VE BEEN, UH ÁP
APPOINTED TO THE BOARD, UM EVERY
BOARD MEETING. WE HAVE WE
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF TITLE IX,
AND UM AND THE BUREAU OF STATE
AUDIT REPORT AND THE COS AND
OCONOR REPORT. UM YOU KNOW, UH,
TRUSTEE BARER MENTIONED, UM THE
UM, ASSOCIATE CHANCELLOR FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS PROGRAMMING. WE
ALSO FORMED A CIVIL RIGHTS
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE TO TRACK AND
ENSURE THAT EVERY RECOMMENDATION
IS IMPLEMENTED AND WE ARE GOING
TO MEET EVERY TIME LINE THAT'S
BEEN SET FORTH. UM UH, AND THAT
OVERSIGHT IS REALLY IT'S
OVERSIGHT AND DIRECTION. ITS
METRICS, RIGHT CASE MANAGEMENT
PREVENTION, EDUCATION AND DATA
COLLECTION, UH, TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE STAYING OUT IN FRONT OF
THIS IT IS A LOT, AND IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WORK WITH ALL
20 THREE CAMPUS PRESIDENTS TO
ENSURE EACH CAMPUS HAS GOT AN
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS, UH, THAT
THOSE METRICS ARE IN PLACE AND
THAT THERE'S CONSTANTLY THIS
BACK AND FORTH FEEDBACK. UM AND
YOU KNOW IT CONTINUES TO EVOLVE,
BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT IS A
TOP PRIORITY FOR US. A QUICK
LAST QUESTION, BECAUSE THIS
MORNING, UM TRUSTEE. I ASKED
ABOUT DIVERSITY AND YOU SAID YOU
HAD MENTIONED, UH, VISITED CAL
POLY AND I SHOULD CLARIFY NOT TO
CAL POLY THAT IS REPRESENTED BY
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE. UH
UH, IT IS Kò POLY IN SAN LOS
OBISPO, BUT THAT YOU HAD A VISIT
THERE. THAT SORT OF REFLECTED ON
THIS WHEN YOU WERE THERE. YES, I
THINK WE WERE TALKING IN TERMS
OF AS FAR AS UM EQUITY AND
STUDENTS THAT FELT INCLUDED A
CERTAIN CAMPUSES OR NOT KIND OF
CHANGING THAT EQUITY GAP AND I
DID GO TO CAL POLY. WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT BLACK STUDENT
SUCCESS, AND I HAD MENTIONED
THAT I WENT TO, UM, THE BLACK
STUDENT, UM, ORGANIZATIONS ON
CAMPUS, WHICH WAS ACTUALLY A
REALLY WONDERFUL MEETING BECAUSE
I WAS ABLE TO TALK TO THE
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS BECAUSE, AS
YOU HAD MENTIONED, CAL POLY HAS
A VERY SMALL SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS. BUT
THESE STUDENTS I SAT WITH AND I
ASKED HOW THEY FELT, AND THEY
ACTUALLY FELT VERY WELCOMED BY
THE STAFF BY THE PROFESSORS, AND
THEY REALLY ENJOYED THEIR TIME
AT CAL POLY ST LOUIS. SO FOR ME,
THAT WAS A GREAT BENCHMARK TO
SEE THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
WORKING AND THE INTENTION BEHIND
THESE PROGRAMS ARE WORKING,
BECAUSE WHEN YOU GO IF YOU LOOK
AT THE NUMBERS, YOU WOULD THINK
THAT THAT'S NOT THE FEELING THEY
HAVE. BUT THEY SAID THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN VERY WELCOMED, AND
THEY KNOW THAT THERE'S AN EXTRA
EFFORT BEING PUT IN TO SUPPORT
THEM. SO FOR US AS TRUSTEES,
THAT'S A GREAT BENCHMARK THAT WE
ARE GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND I KNOW WE
DISCUSSED THE BLACK STUDENT
SUCCESS INITIATIVE, AND I THINK
THAT WAS JUST REALLY CRUCIAL.
INSTRUMENTAL TO HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS WITH OUR
PROFESSORS WITH OUR PRESIDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE TO HAVE OPEN
DIALOGUE ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE
GOING THROUGH, AND HONEST
DIALOGUE, AND THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE JUST PUT
OUT IN A REPORT AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT THAT TO SEE HOW WE
CAN IMPLEMENT THEIR
RECOMMENDATION. STATEWIDE THAT
WAY, WE MAKE SURE WE KEEP
CLOSING THAT EQUITY GAP, UH,
BETWEEN OUR STUDENTS, AND THEY
FEEL MORE WELCOME. AND I KNOW WE
DISCUSSED THIS. IT'S SO
IMPORTANT FOR A STUDENT TO SEE A
PROFESSOR THAT LOOKS LIKE THEM.
IT'S JUST A COMFORTING FEELING
TO GO IN AND YOU LEARN BETTER
AND YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING. UM AND I THINK, UH, I
SPOKE TO IT MYSELF. EARLIER WHEN
I MENTIONED I'M USED TO GOING TO
ROOMS AND I WAS KIND OF THE ONLY
ONE NOBODY KINDA KNEW WHAT I
WAS. WE JUST GUESS, UH, BUT
THAT'S CHANGING, WHICH IS VERY
POSITIVE. AS SHANNON MENTIONED,
IT'S AND I THINK AT THE èC S¼
U. WE ARE VERY DIVERSE AND WE'RE
THE ONE MOST DIVERSE SYSTEMS OUT
THERE. BUT I THINK ARE IT'S TIME
YOU KNOW OUR STAFF AND OUR
FACULTY SHOULD REFLECT THAT AS
WELL. BUT I WAS VERY HAPPY TO
SEE THE CON. WHAT WAS HAPPENING
AT CAL POLY ELO AND HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I APPRECIATE THAT. THANK
YOU. I HAVE A FEW ITEMS WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL ISSUES
THAT THE COMMITTEE I HAVE ONE.
QUICK FOLLOW UP. YES, PLEASE, I.
I WAS GONNA ASK IF YOU COULD
EXPLAIN TO THE COMMITTEE THE
DEFINITION OF OH, OK, SO, UH,
BUT DACA IN PUNJABI MEANS FIRE
WORK OR FIRECRACKER AND SENATOR
GROVE IN OUR COMMUNITY IS KNOWN
AS PATACA. SO SHE IS OUR
FIREWORK OR FIRECRACKER, SO
SHE'S A LITTLE BIT BILINGUAL.
SHE'S UNDERSTANDING PUNJABI. UH,
BUT SHE IS, AND WE GAVE HER THAT
ACCURATE THAT NAME BECAUSE, UM,
SHE IS, AS YOU ALL ARE PRETTY
SURE KNOW, A FIREWORK AND A
FIRECRACKER. BUT UH, WE SAY THAT
ABOUT HER BECAUSE SHE REALLY
FIGHTS FOR HER CONSTITUENTS
REGARDLESS. WHAT IF IT'S A Dð OR
R NEXT TO THEIR NAME, SO SHE'S A
FIREWORK. THERE YOU GO.
SOMETHING NEW TODAY. I JUST
DON'T KNOW WHY I DID THAT.
SENATOR LAIRD. NOW YOU KNOW WHAT
A PATACA IS, AND I GUARANTEE
YOU'RE GONNA KEEP TALKING ABOUT
THAT WORD, BUT I AM BUT I KNEW
WHAT A PAA WAS. I JUST DIDN'T
KNOW THAT WAS THE WORD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HE WANTS THAT
NICKNAME. THAT'S THAT'S WHAT IT
IS. I LOVE THAT. OH, THANK YOU
SO MUCH, UM I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO TOUCH ON TWO ITEMS. CARRYING
FORWARD IN REGARD TO THE
DISCUSSION THAT SENATOR LAIRD
JUST HAD IN REGARDS TO THE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT THAT WE'VE
SEEN ACROSS THE SYSTEM IN JUST
BEING SUPER CANDID ABOUT IT. I
THINK THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
INSTITUTIONS BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE THAT HAVE HAD THEIR DAY
OR CANDIDLY, DAYS OF RECKONING
OF NEEDING TO BE ABLE TO CHANGE
CULTURE WITHIN A SYSTEM AND I
KNOW THAT WE HAVE SEEN THIS CAND
LE ON THE NORTH COAST AND OUR
TWO èC S¼ U CAMPUSES, BOTH CAL
POLY HUMBOLDT AS WELL AS SONOMA
STATE. YOU FEEL THAT THE I HEARD
YOU, DIRECTOR OF THE EUGENE
REGARDS TO OFFICE OF CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT HAS BEEN MADE.
DO YOU FEEL THAT? UH THERE'S
MORE WORK TO COME ON THIS
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM. AND IF
YOU CAN DESCRIBE SPECIFICALLY
WHERE YOU THINK THE SYSTEM NEEDS
TO GO TO ENSURE THAT THAT
CULTURE IS ESTABLISHED AT EACH
OF THE CAMPUSES, IF YOU DON'T
MIND, EACH CHIMING IN WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO KICK US OFF,
MADAM TRUSTY ABSOLUTELY. I THINK
DEFINITELY THERE SHOULD BE MORE
WORK. WE HAVE TO KEEP MOVING
FORWARD ON IT BECAUSE WE NEVER
WANT TO HAVE THIS. THIS
SITUATION HAS TO BE, UM,
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE SHOULD NOT
BE AFRAID TO DISCUSS OR TALK
ABOUT. IT SHOULD BE TOP OF MIND,
AND I THINK THE GOAL WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IS NOT ONLY ARE
WE GOING TO IMPLEMENT THEM, BUT
LIKE I HAD MENTIONED BEFORE,
HAVE WHETHER IT'S A MARKETING
CAMPAIGN AROUND IT TO MAKE SURE
IT STAYS TOP OF MIND. UH, SO
IT'S ALWAYS ON EVERYONE'S RADAR
THAT THIS IS IMPORTANT THAT
THERE'S ZERO TOLERANCE FOR
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TO ZERO
TOLERANCE FOR FOLKS BEHAVING IN
THIS MANNER. SO I THINK THIS IS
GONNA BE CO BECOME PART OF THE
FABRIC OF EVERYTHING WE DO AS A
BOARD AND AS TRUSTEE, GAR AUCHI
MENTIONED THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE DISCUSS AT EVERY SINGLE
MEETING. IT'S NOT GONNA GO AWAY.
MEANING WE WANT IT TO GO AWAY.
YES THAT THAT BEHAVIOR IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE, BUT IT'S NOT GONNA
GO AWAY MEANING AS A PRIORITY
FOR US, AND I THINK THAT IS
WHAT'S COMING OUT OF THIS, UH,
THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND NOW WITH
THE EVERY TWO MONTH BENCHMARKS
AND THEN LIKE I SAID, WE HAD
SUCH A ROBUST AND PRODUCTIVE
MEETING TALKING ABOUT A CAMPAIGN
AROUND THIS, WHETHER IT'S A
SOCIAL MEDIA TIK, TOK SOME
SIMPLE, EFFECTIVE TOOL CAMPAIGN,
UH, ON CAMPUS HAVING BANNERS,
YOU KNOW, CALL THIS NUMBER.
DON'T ASK. DON'T TELL TO THE
POINT WHERE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
LIKE THERE IS ZERO TOLERANCE FOR
THIS SO ABSOLUTELY. I THINK WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE WORKING TOWARDS
THIS BECAUSE WHATEVER HAPPENED
BEFORE IT WAS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
AND WE AS A TRUSTEES TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND NOW THAT THIS IS NOT
AN ADVISORY ROLE. THIS IS AN
OVERSIGHT ROLE, SO THAT'S GONNA
HELP WITH THE ACCOUNTABILITY ON
OUR END. YOU TRUST MR TRESSY?
YEAH, JUST, UH, BUILDING ON
TRUSTY BOROUGH. I MEAN, THIS IS
CULTURAL. UH, CULTURAL RIGHT.
THIS IS BUILDING IN NOT IT'S NOT
A ONE AND DONE IT'S BUILDING IN
AN ONGOING UM UH WAY THAT WE DO
BUSINESS IN THE èC S¼ U. UM IT
HAS TO DO WITH TRAINING IT HAS
TO DO WITH REOCCURRING TRAINING
HAS TO DO WITH THE ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICIES. UM AND IT
HAS TO DO WITH THE ABILITY TO
HAVE SWIFT ACTION WHEN THINGS DO
OCCUR SO THAT, UM, IT DOES NOT
OCCUR AGAIN. AND, UM YOU KNOW,
IT'S THIS IS A VERY LARGE SYSTEM
AND MANY CAMPUSES, UM, WHERE WE
LIKE TO SAY MANY CAMPUSES, BUT
BUT ONE SYSTEM UM AND, UH AND
IT'S INCUMBENT UPON THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES TO NOT BE CASUAL
OBSERVERS, BUT TO BE A, UM, UM,
A ACTIVE UH UH, GUARDIANS OF
THAT, AND THAT IS BEING ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY PROVIDE THAT
OVERSIGHT AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
. YEAH AND AGAIN. THIS IS MORE
OF A COMMENT THAN A QUESTION AND
FOLLOWING UP IS I THINK IT IS
DIFFICULT FOR THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT WHEN AN
INVESTIGATION COMES BACK AND AN
INDIVIDUAL MAY BE DEMOTED BUT
STILL IS EMPLOYED ON CAMPUS AND
THAT INDIVIDUAL IS FOUND GUILTY
OF WHATEVER THAT HARASSMENT MAY
BE CAN STILL BE EMPLOYED AT A
SYSTEM AND, UH, THAT'S GONNA BE
SOME GREATER CHANGE, RIGHT? UM
BUT I THINK THAT IS AN ISSUE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH. AND BY
THE WAY, THIS ISN'T JUST THAT
THE èC S¼ U. WE ALSO SEE THIS
IN THE SYSTEM AS WELL. SO I
DON'T WANT TO SINGLE OUT THE èC
S¼ U SYSTEM. BUT THAT IS AN
ISSUE THAT TERM THAT WE'RE GOING
TO NEED TO BE ABLE TO WORK
THROUGH. AND THERE ARE SOME
ADDITIONAL HURDLES THERE. I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE THERE HAS
BEEN SOME SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADVANCED ON THAT, UM AND
WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
THOSE AREN'T THE FOLKS THAT WE
WILL WANT WORKING WITH OUR KIDS
STUDENTS RIGHT OR INTERMINGLING
WITH FACULTY. UM I'D LIKE TO BE
AT A TRANSITION TO THE ISSUE OF
COW POLY. HUMBLE UM AND I WILL
RARELY BRING MY OWN AGENDA INTO
THIS. BUT LOOK, THE INVESTMENT
THAT THE STATE IS MAKING IN ONE
OF THE MOST RURAL PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA'S LITERALLY A GAME
CHANGER FOR ONE OF THE MOST
IMPOVERISHED AREAS OF OUR STATE,
AND, UH, TRULY GRATEFUL FOR WHAT
WE'VE SEEN, AND THIS IS GOING TO
BE A GAME CHANGER. WHEN IT COMES
TO THE OFFERINGS OF STUDENTS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A GAME
CHANGER FOR THE LOCAL ECONOMY AS
WE'RE GOING TO BUSINESSES START
UP. IT'S GOING TO BE A GAME
CHANGER FOR PRIVATE EMPLOYERS
OFFERING HEALTH CARE BENEFITS
BASED OFF OF THE TYPE OF
BUSINESS THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO, UH, BOUND IN THEIR
HOMETOWN WHERE THEY WENT TO
COLLEGE, JUST LIKE WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IN POMONA AND WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IN, UM IN TOWNS, BISPO. AND
WE'RE IN TWO YEARS, I THINK INTO
A NINE YEAR PLAN. UM PRESIDENT
JACKSON IS PLOWING HARD AT THIS
IN CONSTANT CONTACT WITH
PRESIDENT JACKSON UP AT HUMBOLDT
, BUT JUST CHECKING IN MAKING
SURE THAT YOU ARE, UH, NÓ. YOU
HAVE A LOT GOING ON, BUT ALSO
FOCUSING ON HUMBOLDT. AND I
THINK THE BIGGEST CONCERN THAT
WE HAVE IN HUMBOLDT IS ONE IS
MAKING SURE THAT WE KEEP ON TIME
AND THEN TWO THE ISSUE OF
HOUSING, RIGHT UH AND, UH,
STUDENT HOUSING, AND THAT HAS
BEEN THE BIGGEST ISSUE BY THE
WAY. IT IS AN ISSUE SYSTEM WIDE
AND JUST WANT TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT AS WELL. WE'D
LOVE TO HAVE YOU OUT BY THE WAY.
WELL I'LL START OFF. I MEAN, AS
YOU I THINK YOU KNOW YOUR
HOMETOWN. IT'S MY FAMILY IS FROM
COUNTY. SO UH AND IT HAS YOU
KNOW, WE WERE ABLE TO SEE YOU
KNOW, CAL, STAY HUMBLE IN ITS
HEYDAY AND THEN YOU KNOW, AS AS
AS THE CHALLENGES OCCURRED. UM,
THIS THIS IS ACTUALLY A REBIRTH
AND IT'S REALLY BEEN A GAME
CHANGER FOR, UM, FOR HUMBOLDT
COUNTY. AND UH, AND FOR THE
REGION, NORTH COAST. YEAH. YEAH
SO AND WE APPRECIATE THAT, UH,
IMMENSELY. UM, I, I THINK THE
ISSUE OF YOU KNOW, WE AT THE AND
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS AT THE
IN THE ON THE BOARD AND IS THE
IS, YOU KNOW, IT'S WE'RE OUT OF
PLACE NOW, WHERE CAL POLY
HUMBOLDT IS LAUNCHED, AND IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US TO KEEP IT
GOING RIGHT, MAKING IT A
SUCCESS. AND THAT HAS TO COME IN
THE CONTEXT OF ALL OF THE
PRIORITIES THAT WE NEED TO, UH
TO ADDRESS. BUT YOU KNOW, WHEN
YOU HAVE AAA NEW SORT OF
UNIVERSITY LIKE THAT IT IT TAKES
EXTRA RESOURCES AND EXTRA FOCUS.
UM, HOUSING. IS THE PROBABLY ONE
OF THE BIGGEST THING WE HAVE
ACROSS THE CAMP ACROSS THE
SYSTEM WIDE. UH BUT IN IN THAT
RURAL PART OF THE STATE, IT IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT, RIGHT?
SO UM, II, I CAN JUST TELL YOU,
UH, SENATOR THAT IT'S UH IT IS A
TOPIC THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED AND
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS, UH, ON THE
BOARD AND HOW WE CAN CONTINUE TO
DO WHAT WE CAN TO MAKE THAT A
SUCCESSFUL ENDEAVOR. THANK YOU.
UH AGAIN, ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
TRUSTEE GAL. DCI UH, WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT CAL POLY
HUMBOLDT. THINK OF A WONDERFUL
WONDERFUL I KNOW. YOU'VE BEEN
REALLY INSTRUMENTAL IN PUSHING
FOR THAT. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
UM THIS IS ABSOLUTELY WONDERFUL
WHEN YOU DO HAVE LEGISLATURES
THAT ARE LEGISLATORS THAT ARE
PASSIONATE ABOUT THE AND THEIR
AREAS, AND WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE JUST A GAME CHANGER
AND IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE AS
TIME GOES ON TO BE A GAME
CHANGER. SO WE'RE VERY COGNIZANT
OF THAT, AND THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT. THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO DO
AS THE èC S¼ U AS IS TO BRING
THINGS THAT ARE, UM GONNA, YOU
KNOW, MAKE THE COMMUNITIES
THRIVE AND OUR STUDENTS SUCCESS
AND I THINK CAL POLY HUMBOLDT
WILL IS GONNA BE, UH, A CASE
STUDY GOING FORWARD FOR A LOT OF
FOLKS AND HOW SUCCESSFUL IT'S
GOING TO BE FOR THAT COMMUNITY
ECONOMICALLY AND FOR OUR
STUDENTS, SO WE'RE WE'RE
THRILLED WITH IT. WE THINK IT'S
A WONDERFUL PROJECT. YEAH AND,
UH AGAIN, I WON'T, UH, LORD OVER
THIS, BUT II, I CANNOT STRESS
ENOUGH THAT THE 458 MILLION IT.
IT IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE
LARGEST INVESTMENTS THAT WE HAVE
SEEN IN A RURAL AREA BESIDES
BUILDING A PRISON UM AND YOU
COULD YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
SEE OVER THE NEXT DECADE
GENERATIONAL CHANGE THAT WILL BE
BROUGHT TO THE COMMUNITY. UM
AGAIN, JUST PRIVATELY HELD JOBS
WITH HEALTHCARE INSURANCE. IT'S
GOING TO BE SKYROCKETING. WE'VE
WE'LL SEE THE TYPE OF JOBS THAT
WILL NOW BE OFFERED AND GETTING
AWAY FROM THAT RESOURCE BASED
ECONOMY. IT IS A GAME CHANGER,
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE DO
IT RIGHT. WHAT I APPRECIATE IS
THAT PRESIDENT JACKSON AT Kò
HUMBOLDT PRESIDENT, FLAMER
COLLEGE. WOODS THEY ARE WORKING
CLOSER THAN EVER. WE HAVE A
HEALTHCARE EDUCATION HUB, A JOB
HUB THAT WILL BE OPENED UP
30,000 SQUARE FOOT WAREHOUSE
THAT WE'RE TRANSITIONING WITH
SOME ADDITIONAL DOLLARS THAT WE
GOT AN EARMARK FROM THE STATE.
THAT IS ANOTHER PIECE. I'M A
FIRM BELIEVER THAT THIS AND I'M
BIASED MESUM. UM AND THE èC S¼
U SYSTEM IS THE WORKHORSE OF OUR
POST SECONDARY SYSTEM. IN HAVING
THAT FOCUS ON HEALTHCARE JOBS IS
AN ISSUE THAT MADAM VICE CHAIR
HAS IN HER DISTRICT, ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO HEALTH CARE. MR
LAIRD HAS IN HIS DISTRICT HAS,
AND I'M NOT TRYING TO SINGLE
OUT. UM, MR JONES, BUT, UH, IT'S
I THINK FOR A RURAL AREA, I. I
REALLY HOPE THAT THIS CAN BECOME
A MODEL AND I JUST HOPING THAT
CONTINUED FOCUS ON THAT IS GONNA
BE A KEY FOR YOU AND THE REST OF
THE TRUSTEES. AND WITH THAT, I
WANT TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS, COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE TODAY. Tð
BAR. THANK YOU, UH, FOR
APPEARING TODAY. WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL. IT'S WONDERFUL BY THE
WAY TO HAVE YOUR DAUGHTER HERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. UH AND, UM, I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
I'M GONNA GET EMOTIONAL TALK
ABOUT DIRECTOR GAD DCI FOR
EVERYTHING THAT HE'S DONE FOR
OUR COMMUNITY. UH AND I ALWAYS
CRY WHEN I SEE HIM. UH, BECAUSE,
UH, WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH SO
MUCH, UH, WITH FIRE AFTER FIRE
AFTER FIRE CLEANING UP LITERALLY
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF HOMES OVER
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS. IT HAS
BEEN DEVASTATING AND YOU HAVE
BEEN THERE EVERY SEPARATE WAY.
SO THANK YOU. AND I'M GLAD
YOU'RE THERE. AND BEFORE I GET
TOO BLUBBERY, I'M GONNA MOVE ON,
UH TO PUBLIC COMMENT. UH, YOU
CAN COME UP AND GET BLUBBERY
WITH US IF YOU'D LIKE, UH AND
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING FOR THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE TWO TRUSTEES.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE, PLEASE
ADVANCE AT THIS TIME TO THE
PODIUM. LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT. WE NOW GOING TO
ASK THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE. THERE IS SOMEONE IN
OPPOSITION. THE FIRECRACKER MAY
BE THROWING A BRICK AT YOU, BUT,
UM ANYTHING ELSE? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE AT THIS TIME? ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS PLEASE BEAM
VICE CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE A MOTION THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR. I ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE CHAIR ABOUT
GETTING BLUBBERY WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT IT. THAT'S WHY THEY WANT
TO ASK YOU QUESTIONS. I KNOW
YOU'RE BOTH QUALIFIED AND YOU
HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLE ON EVERY
DISASTER THAT WE HAVE, AND YOU
HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLE. UPLIFTING
MY COMMUNITY AND I CAN'T. UM
TELL YOU THANK YOU BOTH VERY
MUCH FOR WILLING TO TAKE ON THE
èC S¼ U SYSTEM. AND SO I WOULD
BE HONORED TO MOVE BOTH OF THE
COMPS TO THE FLOOR FOR FULL
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
VERY GRATEFUL, MADAM VICE CHAIR.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE? I GROVE
GROVE. I EGIN JONES. JONES I
LAIRD LAIRD. I ON CALL THAT'S
CURRENTLY 4 TO 0 VOTE THAT'S
GOING TO BE RAIN ON CALL. MADAM
TRUSTEE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE, MR. TRUSTY ALWAYS
GOOD TO SEE YOU SAID LINDA. MY
GOODNESS. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE
APPOINT A PERSONAL PRIVILEGE AND
ASK THE MONEY TO COME UP AND
TAKE A PICTURE WITH HER MOM AT
THIS INCREDIBLE MOMENT. WHY
DON'T WE DO THAT? COME ON UP AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'LL TAKE A
TWO MINUTE LET'S TAKE A TWO
MINUTE RECESS. TWO MINUTE
RECESS, PLEASE. STAND RIGHT HERE
WITH YOUR NAME.
ALL RIGHT, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK INTO
COMMITTEE. WE ARE GOING TO
WELCOME MS ERICKSON. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD, CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES AND WE ARE
GRATEFUL WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HUMAN RESOURCES CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. IT'S REALLY
GOOD TO SEE YOU AND YOU WILL
HAVE A MINUTE OR TWO TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE OPENING COMMENTS AND
WE WELCOME THOSE. WE ARE GOING
TO OPEN IT UP FOR MEMBERS FOR
ANY QUESTIONS, COMMENTS THAT
THEY MAY HAVE IN YOUR OPENING.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO WELCOME MANY
GUESTS THAT YOU MAY HAVE THAT
ARE EITHER WATCHING OR HERE IN
THE ROOM TODAY AND WE WILL BE
KEEPING A CLOSE EYE ON THE
TIMING OF YOUR OPENING. AND I'M
NOT TRYING TO BE RUDE. I'LL GIVE
YOU A 32ND HEADS UP. IT'S
WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH IN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU. IT IS MY PRIVILEGE
AND PLEASURE TO APPEAR BEFORE
YOU TODAY, I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO THANK
GOVERNOR NEWSOM, THE
ADMINISTRATION AND DIRECTOR
ARENA ORTEGA FOR APPOINTING ME
TO THIS POSITION. I APPROACH
THIS APPOINTMENT WITH PRIDE AND
ENTHUSIASM AND I AM COMMITTED TO
THIS WORK DUE TO MY OWN
EXPERIENCES. WHEN I WAS SEEKING
EMPLOYMENT, HIRED, TRAINED AND
MENTORED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHAPE AND INNOVATE. THE HIRING
PROCESS WOULD BE REWARDING AS IT
BRINGS A POSITIVE IMPACT AND A
MEANINGFUL DIFFERENCE IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES. THE PERCEPTION
THAT IT'S DIFFICULT TO GET A
STATE JOB IS A STATEMENT THAT I
WANNA CHANGE. TO INNOVATE. THE
STATE HIRING PROCESS IS A GOAL
WE CAN ACHIEVE. NOT JUST Kò HÌ
R. DEPARTMENTS TOGETHER AS A
TEAM. I WANNA THANK THE
INCREDIBLE LEADERS AND
COLLEAGUES WHO MODELED THE WAY
FOR ME AND MENTORED ME
THROUGHOUT MY 34 YEARS OF STATE
SERVICE. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
AND TALKING ABOUT GETTING
BLUBBERY MY FORMER, UH, HEALTH
CARE, ACCESS AND INFORMATION
STAFF IS HERE TODAY IN THE
AUDIENCE. UNFORTUNATELY MY
FAMILY COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY,
BUT THEY ARE WATCHING. I'D LIKE
TO THANK MY AUNT AND UNCLE
MONICA. PETER FACS, MY HUSBAND,
NEIL ERICKSON. AND MY MOM WHO'S
WATCHING ME FROM HEAVEN ABOVE,
UH, FOR BEING A STRONG SUPPORT
SYSTEM IN MY LIFE THAT CONCLUDES
MY OPENING REMARKS AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH. DEPUTY DIRECTOR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. IT IS AN ABSOLUTE
PLEASURE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE YOU
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE. THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO OPEN IT UP TO COMMITTEES
TO BE THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
NOW IS THE TIME TO ADVANCE THOSE
FROM COMMITTEE. EXPLAINED BY
CHAIR FOR YOU. THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR. GOOD MORNING, DIRECTOR.
HOW ARE YOU? I AM GOOD. THANK
YOU OR GOOD AFTERNOON. UM I WAS
LOOKING AT YOUR RESPONSES IN THE
RULES COMMITTEE. AND YOU
INDICATED THAT RECRUITING AND
HIRING AND RETAINING EMPLOYEES
HAS BECOME CHALLENGING. AND UM,
IN THE REAL WORLD. I HAVE A
BUSINESS AND THAT IS ONE OF OUR
MOST CHALLENGING ASPECTS THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT. RECRUITING THEM TO.
UM I DON'T WANNA SAY COVID
RUINED A LOT OF PEOPLE TO WORK
FROM HOME. BUT THERE ARE A LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT DON'T WANT TO
COME TO A REGULAR 40 HOUR A WEEK
JOB BECAUSE THEY FEEL LIKE THEY
CAN HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
COMMUNITY FROM HOME, BUT NOT
ALWAYS. WE ACCOMMODATE THAT. SO
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU'RE DOING TO RECRUIT PEOPLE?
UM THAT CAN STILL MAINTAIN, UM,
THE INTEGRITY THAT WE NEED AT
KELLY CHAR. I HAVE SOME
WONDERFUL NEWS TO SHARE WITH YOU
ON SOME OF THE GREAT WORK THAT
Kò HÌ R IS DOING. SO UM, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU KNOW I KEEP
HEARING AND NOTICING, AND IT'S
REALLY HARD TO GET THROUGH THE
CAL CAREER SYSTEM, RIGHT? WHICH
IS THE PORTAL WHERE EVERYBODY
APPLIES. BUT I DO WANNA LET YOU
KNOW THAT WE ARE WORKING ON
CHANGING THAT WEBSITE WHERE
MAKING IT EASIER TO SEARCH FOR
JOBS. SO IF PEOPLE WANT TO LOOK
FOR A HYBRID TYPE OF JOB, THEY
CAN FIND IT A LOT EASIER. WE'RE
ALSO DESIGNING THE WEBSITE, SO
IT'S EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO
ACCESS. UM AND ALSO BE ABLE TO
JUST NAVIGATE. UH, THE OTHER
THING IS, WE'RE EXPLORING A LOT
OF THE THINGS THAT WE DO WITH
EXAMS AND REDESIGNING THEM. UM
THE OTHER VERY EXCITING THING
THAT I'M VERY HAPPY TO REPORT IS
ON APRIL 8TH. WE ARE GOING TO BE
LAUNCHING A WORK FOR CALIFORNIA
CAMPAIGN. WORK FOR CALIFORNIA IS
ENCOMPASSES ITS CENTRALIZED, SO
IT'S GOING TO, UM, ALLOW US TO
ADVERTISE, UH, FOR ALL STATE
DEPARTMENTS TOGETHER UNDER THAT
UMBRELLA. YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
WORK FOR CALIFORNIA ON BUSES,
LIGHT RAIL AND HIGHWAY 50. SO IN
MY 34 YEARS OF SERVICE, I'VE
NEVER SEEN THAT BEFORE. SO I'M
REALLY EXCITED THAT WE'RE
INNOVATING AND GETTING THAT
MESSAGE OUT. UM I'LL JUST SHARE
WITH YOU THAT I FIND AT TIMES
OUR YOUNGER GENERATION, WHETHER
IT WAS A COVID THING OR NOT, A
LOT OF THEM DON'T EVEN
UNDERSTAND STATE GOVERNMENT AND
THAT WE'RE HERE AND WE NEED TO
REACH THAT GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS.
SO WE'RE HOPEFULLY GONNA START
INNOVATING SOME MORE SO THEY CAN
SEE US AND BE MORE TRANSPARENT.
THE OTHER THING I WANTED TO
SHARE WITH YOU IS, YOU KNOW,
GETTING THEM THROUGH THE PORTAL
IS ONE THING. THE OTHER PIECE TO
ALL OF THIS IS HELPING THEM
THROUGH THE WHOLE HIRING PROCESS
. UNDERSTANDING ALL OF THE
DOCUMENTS, UM, WHICH CAN BE VERY
CUMBERSOME AT TIMES. SO WHAT
CALLIE CHAR IS DOING AS WELL AS
WE'RE HOSTING OPEN HOUSES SO WE
CAN HAVE PEOPLE OPEN FORUMS.
EXCUSE ME SO WE CAN HAVE PEOPLE
COME TO CAL HÌ R, AND WE WILL
KIND OF WALK THEM THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND HANDHOLD THEM A
LITTLE BIT. I THINK WE NEED THAT
ALL OF YOU HAVE HEARD IT TAKES A
FAMILY MEMBER TO GET THROUGH THE
PROCESS. WELL WE'RE GOING TO
CHANGE THAT. WE WANNA BE SURE TO
HAVE HANDS ON AND LET THEM KNOW
THAT WE'RE THERE. UM AND THEN I
WANT TO ALSO SHARE WITH YOU THAT
WE ARE ALSO DOING OTHER VERY
LARGE PROJECTS. UM THERE'S THIS
GENERALIST CONSOLIDATION THAT I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE HEARD OF,
UM, BUT WHAT THE CONSOLIDATION
WILL DO IS GOING TO TAKE
DISTINCT WORKS OF BODY SUPPORT,
TECHNICAL AND ANALYTICAL
POSITIONS AND KIND OF SMASH THEM
ALL DOWN, SO WE DON'T HAVE SO
MANY BROAD CLASSIFICATIONS OUT
THERE. UM THE PROPOSAL IS GONNA
COLLAPSE CLASSES UNTIL, LIKE,
EIGHT SERVICE WIDE CLASSES AND,
UM NOT ALLOW FOR SO MUCH
COMPLEXITY WHEN WE'RE APPLYING
FOR JOBS, YOU KNOW, THERE'S LIKE
2600 CLASSIFICATIONS. THAT'S A
LOT AND IT'S A LOT TO MANAGE. UM
THE OTHER THING THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS APPRENTICESHIPS
SOMETHING THAT I'M REALLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT, UM, OBVIOUSLY
INVESTING IN OUR CURRENT
EMPLOYEES THROUGH NONTRADITIONAL
APPRENTICESHIPS IS A VERY AN
AREA THAT I'M VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT. THIS PROGRAM IS GONNA
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
CURRENT STATE EMPLOYEES TO
ACHIEVE EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO MEET THE
MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS AND THEN
THEY CAN MOVE ON INTO, UM THE
CAREER LADDER, WHICH IS
WONDERFUL NEWS. UM I CAN GO ON
AND ON SO I CAN CONTINUE IF YOU
LIKE. THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF
THAT I CAN SHARE WITH YOU. I DO
HAVE ONE FINAL QUESTION IS NEAR
AND DEAR TO MY HEART, YOU KNOW,
I KNOW IT'S HARD FOR PEOPLE TO
BELIEVE. BUT I WAS A PRETTY
ROTTEN KID WHEN I WAS GROWING UP
AND I WENT TO CONTINUATION HIGH
SCHOOL AND JUST HAVING THE èC
S¼ U CONFERENCE HERE. I PROBABLY
WOULDN'T SAY THIS TO THEM. BUT
YOU KNOW, NOT EVERYBODY HAS A
COLLEGE EDUCATION AND A DEGREE,
INCLUDING ME, UM, BARELY
GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL AND I'M
ONE OF 40 IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I, UM KNOW THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE DISQUALIFIED FROM KELLY
CHAIR JOBS BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THAT DEGREE BUT COULD BE
VERY VALUABLE ASSETS. UM UH TO
THIS STATE? UM SECOND CHANCERS,
FOR EXAMPLE, THAT HAVE A HEART
AND PASSION TO DO SERVICE. SO
CAN YOU TELL ME ABOUT THE
EXPANSION OF ELIMINATING THAT
REQUIREMENT FOR A DEGREE IN
ORDER TO EXPAND NOT ONLY
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOSE OUT THERE WITHOUT A DEGREE
, THAT WOULD BE VERY BENEFICIAL
TO THE STATE. UM COULD YOU
EXPAND ON THAT FOR ME, PLEASE?
ABSOLUTELY. UM, WHAT I AM VERY
PROUD TO SHARE WITH YOU IS WE
HAVE REMOVED BARRIERS OF
EMPLOYMENT SPECIFICALLY WHAT
YOU'RE ADDRESSING FROM 169 JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS. UM WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO DO MORE. IT IS AN
ONGOING EFFORT THAT WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT. BROADEN AND EXPAND.
UM THE MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS
FOR SOME OF THESE POSITIONS
WHERE EDUCATION IS NOT REQUIRED.
SO THERE'S MANY DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT WE CAN GO ABOUT DOING THIS,
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT Kò HÌ
R DID WAS WE PUT OUT A POLICY TO
EXPLAIN TO STATE DEPARTMENTS
THAT WHEN THEY ARE LOOKING AT
CLASSIFICATIONS, AND THEY DO
THEIR JOB ANALYSIS, DOES IT
REQUIRE AN EDUCATION COMPONENT?
IF IT DOESN'T WE HAVE A PROCESS
FORWARD TO HAVE THEM ALERT US OF
THIS. UM IN THE MEANTIME, WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THE THINGS
DEPARTMENTS ARE TELLING US IN
THE STRUGGLES THAT THEY'RE
HAVING WITH HIRING, AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE LOOKING AT ALL OF
THOSE THINGS SO ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S SOME OF THE WORK THAT WE
ARE CONTINUING TO DO AT CAL HÌ R
THAT I'M VERY PROUD OF. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR. PLEASE, SENATOR
LAIRD. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MADA
VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU, I. I LIKE
TO FOLLOW UP A LITTLE BIT AND
MAYBE ASK ONE OF THE CONCERNS OF
SENATOR GROVE A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT WAY BECAUSE IN OUR
BACKUP IT, IT SAYS THAT THERE'S
A 20% VACANCY RATE. AND THAT'S
REALLY HIGH AND SO WITH A 20%
VACANCY RATE FIRST, I'D MAYBE I
WILL HAVE A FOLLOW UP. BUT FIRST
I'D ASK. WHY DO YOU THINK THAT'S
TRUE? DO YOU THINK THE PROCESS
TAKES TOO LONG? DO YOU THINK THE
PAY ISN'T HIGH ENOUGH? DO YOU
THINK THERE AREN'T QUALIFIED
PEOPLE OUT THERE FOR THE
SPECIFIC JOBS? WHAT ARE THE
REASONS THAT YOU BELIEVE THERE
IS A 20% VACANCY RATE AND
ACTUALLY, I AM HAPPY TO REPORT
THE VACANCY RATE HAS DROPPED. WE
ARE AT 19.7 AS OF TODAY. THEN
LET ME ASK YOU. WHY DO YOU THINK
THERE'S A 19.7? OH, SO I WILL
SHARE WITH YOU THIS. UM BUT IF
IT'S GONNA DROP MORE DURING YOUR
TESTIMONY, IT'S DROPPING AS WE
SPEAK, SIR, IT IS DROPPING AS WE
SPEAK. UM I. I APOLOGIZE, BUT I
THINK THE GOOD SENATOR SHOULD
LOOK AT THE POSITIVE THINGS THAT
YOU HAVE DONE. AND JUST, UH,
HONOR YOU FOR THAT GOOD WORK OF
DROPPING THAT RATE. UM I WILL
GET THERE AND THAT'S THE REASON
SHE'S A FIRECRACKER. I WANT TO
BE THE FIRECRACKER, TOO. BUT, UM
SO LET'S TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THIS, UM I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT OUR STATE VACANCY RATE HAS
GROWN. FROM 14 TO 20.7% OVER THE
PAST SIX YEARS IN 2018, WE HAD
220,000 FULL TIME EQUIVALENT,
UM, POSITIONS. IN 2023. WE NOW
HAVE 242,000 SO THE AUTHORIZED
POSITIONS HAVE INCREASED
TREMENDOUSLY. HOWEVER THE STATE
VACANCY RATE DOESN'T TELL YOU
THE WHOLE STORY. BUT I'M GONNA
TELL YOU THE STORY, OK, WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS OF EMPLOYEES
IN OUR STATE WORKFORCE, WE CAN
SEE THAT EMPLOYMENT HAS ACTUALLY
GROWN OVER TIME. IN 2018. WE HAD
230,000 EMPLOYEES WORKING. BY
2023 WE HAD ABOUT 236,000
EMPLOYEES. SO IS HIRING. ARE WE
HIRING ENOUGH STATE WORKERS IS
THE QUESTION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
ASK OURSELVES. UM OVER THE PAST
SIX YEARS, STATE AGENCIES HAVE
HIRED 19,000 NEW TO SERVICE
STATE EMPLOYEES EACH YEAR. WE
CAN SEE THAT WE DID HAVE TROUBLE
HIRING IN 2021. I'M AN ASSOCIATE
THAT PROBABLY COVID RETIREMENTS,
RIGHT? UH, WE HIRED LESS THAN
18,000 AROUND THAT TIME. BUT THE
GOOD NEWS IS BY 2023. WE HIRED
MORE THAN 20,000 NEW STATE
WORKERS. EACH YEAR. THOUSANDS OF
STATE EMPLOYEES CHANGED JOBS,
WHICH IS GREAT. WE WANT THEM TO
DO THAT. IT'S VERY GOOD FOR
DEPARTMENTS, RIGHT? WE'RE
INCREASING THEIR SKILL SET.
THEY'RE GETTING THEIR
PROMOTIONS. UM BUT OF COURSE,
THEN THAT POSES CHALLENGES TO
BACKFILL THOSE POSITIONS. ARE WE
KEEPING UP WITH THE HIRING? SO
THE QUESTION WE ASK OURSELVES IS
ARE WE HIRING MORE EMPLOYEES
EACH YEAR THAN LEAVE THE STATE?
AND IT COULD BE FOR RETIREMENT
OR FOR OTHER REASONS. WHAT WE
SEE IS IN 2018 THROUGH 2020. WE
HIRED 3000 MORE WORKERS EACH
YEAR, THEN LEFT US BUT IN 2021
22, OF COURSE, WE BARELY KEPT
PACE. SO AGAIN, I WANT TO
REITERATE THAT THERE IS SOME
GOOD NEWS HERE. AS I'M SPEAKING,
WE'RE REDUCING THAT VACANCY RATE
AND IN 2023 WE HIRED ABOUT 4000
MORE NEW EMPLOYEES THAN THOSE
THAT LEFT STATE SERVICE. AM
TRYING TO PUT SOME ANALYSIS TO
THE STATISTICS THAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT, BECAUSE IT SOUNDS
IN THE EARLY STATISTICS THAT WE
WERE ACTUALLY KEEPING UP. IT'S
JUST THAT THE NUMBER OF JOBS WAS
GROWING STATE GOVERNMENT GREW,
SO I'M JUST LOOKING FOR A CLEAR
STATEMENT IS THAT ONE OF THE
MAJOR REASONS FOR THE 20%
VACANCY RATE IS THAT IT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN 14% OF THE JOBS.
NUMBER OF JOBS THAT REMAIN THE
SAME. BUT IT GREW AND THEN YOU
HAD TO FILL THEM. YES SIR. I
WOULD SAY THAT'S IT. AND THEN,
IF THERE'S THAT MANY VACANT AND
YOU HAVE TO CATCH UP THAT THE
PROCESS TAKE AN INCREDIBLY LONG
TIME. SO THE MINUTE YOU START TO
HAVE VACANCIES THAT FEEDS ON
ITSELF AND IN HAVING ENOUGH
STAFF TO FILL AND HOW LONG IT
TAKES TO FILL A VACANCY. SO
THERE THERE'S DIFFERENT
POSITIONS ON THIS, AND I'M JUST
GONNA TELL YOU HOW I FEEL ABOUT
THIS. IT IS A LOT OF WORK FOR A
STATE DEPARTMENT TO HIRE PEOPLE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN ONE JOB YOU GET
ABOUT 100 APPLICATIONS FOR THAT
POSITION. THESE MANAGERS GET
PULLED AWAY FROM THEIR DAY TO
DAY JOBS TO KIND OF SCREEN
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE AND THEN,
UNFORTUNATELY, THE RESULT IS NOT
AS MANY QUALIFIED APPLICANTS AS
THEY HOPED. YES, THE PROCESS IS
LONG. YES DEPARTMENTS HAVE TO
DEDICATE RESOURCES IN ORDER TO
DO THIS. RAPIDLY HIRING. OK YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HIRE SOMEBODY
IN 45 DAYS. HOWEVER, THINGS ARE
TAKING A LOT LONGER, BECAUSE I
THINK WE GET SUCH AN INFLUX OF
APPLICANTS AND THEN THE MANAGER
SPENDS A LOT OF TIME LOOKING
THROUGH THOSE APPLICATIONS TO NÓ
AVAIL OF NOT GETTING ENOUGH
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES. WHAT I
WILL SAY TO THAT IS DEPARTMENTS
HAVE TO DEDICATE THE RESOURCES
IN ORDER TO DO THAT. TO HIRE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. IF YOU
DON'T YOU START LOSING QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS, WHICH IS A PROBLEM.
IS THE STATE HIRING PROCESS
CUMBERSOME? YES, IT CAN BE A
LONG PROCESS. WE WANT TO ENSURE
MERIT BASED HIRING PROCESS SO
THERE ARE STEPS REQUIRED TO
THAT. CAN WE DO IT FASTER?
ABSOLUTELY CAN WE MAKE IT MORE
SIMPLE? YES, WE'RE WORKING
TOWARDS THAT. I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF, UM THINGS THAT WE CAN DO
TOGETHER. CLEAR JOB POSTINGS. SO
IT'S VERY CLEAR WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR, SO WE JUST DON'T
GET THESE INFLUX OF
APPLICATIONS. POSSIBLY
SIMPLIFYING JOB DUTY STATEMENTS
IN PLAIN LANGUAGE SO PEOPLE CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE JOB IS AND
REMOVING A LOT OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT JARGON THAT WE HAVE.
I MEAN, SOME OF THESE DUTY
STATEMENTS ARE SO OLD OUT THERE,
SO THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS WE
CAN DO. TO SHORTEN THAT HIRING
PROCESS FIRST. I CAN'T TOTALLY
SPEAK FOR OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, BUT I WOULD SAY WE
WOULD OBVIOUSLY BE COMMITTED TO
HAVING A MUCH LOWER VACANCY RATE
AND FILL POSITIONS AS SOON AS WE
CAN. AND THEN THE QUESTION IS,
WHAT DO YOU DO? AND I HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES ON THIS.
I HAPPEN TO HAVE HEADED A STATE
AGENCY FOR EIGHT YEARS THAT HAD
19,000 PEOPLE IN IT, AND THERE
WERE TIMES WHEN WE HAD
EMERGENCIES. WE NEEDED PEOPLE AS
G WE COULD AND WE LOOKED FOR. I
GUESS THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
IS PASSED. WE LOOK FOR EVERY WAY
TO MANIPULATE THE SYSTEM TO GET
PEOPLE IN EMERGENCY NÓ. I DON'T
WANT TO HEAR THAT. WELL, NÓ. I
MEAN, WE STUCK BY THE RULES, BUT
WE HAD TO WORK IT BECAUSE IF A
PLACE IS BURNING DOWN AND YOU
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH EMERGENCY
FIREFIGHTERS, YOU HAVE TO HAVE
ENOUGH EMERGENCY FIREFIGHTERS.
AND SO WHAT I'M TRYING TO
COMMUNICATE IS THAT THERE IS
SOME URGENCY HERE AND WHEN I WAS
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL, NOT
AN ELECTED ONE. I WORKED IN THE
PERSONNEL DEPARTMENT AND IT TOOK
US EIGHT MONTHS OR 10 MONTHS TO
FILL A ACCOUNTING POSITION, AND
I HEADED A TASK FORCE WHERE WE
LOOKED AT EVERY STAGE OF THE
PROCESS AND CUT THE TIME DOWN
AND REALLY WORKED TO MOVE IT.
AND SO I WAS JUST TRYING TO ASK
ANALYTICALLY. WHAT IS THE REASON
FOR THIS? AND HOW DO WE ADDRESS
THE REASON? BECAUSE WE HAVE TO?
YOU KNOW, AND IT WASN'T JUST
FIREFIGHTERS. IT WAS LIKE FISH
AND WILDLIFE OFFICERS. IT WAS
JUST ANY OF A NUMBER OF THINGS
WHERE THERE WAS AN URGENCY TO
THE WORK THAT WAS DONE. AND SO
IT'S A QUÊ. AND LET'S BE HONEST.
IF YOU'RE IS A BAD BUDGET YEAR,
BUT IF YOU NEED MORE RESOURCES,
AND THAT WILL ABSOLUTELY PRODUCE
LESS VACANCIES. THAT'S A FAIR
THING TO MAKE SURE IS STATED IF
THERE IS A PROCESS THAT NEEDS TO
BE FIXED AND IT SOMEHOW CAN
REQUIRE LEGISLATIVE ACTION
RATHER THAN ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTION. THEN WE NEED TO KNOW,
BUT IT'S LIKE IT. IT'S TRYING TO
GET A SENSE THAT THERE'S THAT
MANAGEMENT OVERVIEW. THERE'S NOT
ANALYSIS WITH THAT URGENCY THAT
IS GOING TO MOVE ON THIS IN IN A
CLEAR WAY, AND I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU WANNA COMMENT BECAUSE WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING FOR WAYS TO DO
THAT. I ACTUALLY DO BECAUSE, UM,
ONE OF THE THINGS I WANTED TO
START DOING WHICH MY TEAM IS
WORKING ON RIGHT NOW IS, UH,
WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND IS IF
YOU HAVE AN I Tð CLASSIFICATION,
WE'LL JUST GO WITH I Tð
SOMETHING SIMPLE. YOU THINK?
WELL THE LOWER CLASSIFICATIONS
CALL CENTERS AND A COMMON
LANGUAGE. UM WHY IS IT THAT EACH
STATE DEPARTMENT IS DOING
INDIVIDUALIZED HIRING? WHY IS IT
THAT WE CAN'T ALL GET TOGETHER
AS A GROUP AND HAVE MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS GET TOGETHER AND SAY
, I'VE GOT THREE VACANCIES HERE?
Dð Ó R. YOU'VE GOT SO MANY
VACANCIES HERE. èC Dð èC R.
YOU'VE GOT VACANCIES HERE, SAME
CLASSIFICATION, AND WE ALL GET
TOGETHER AND DO SOME KIND OF A
RAPID HIRING. EVENT IT'S
POSSIBLE TO DO THAT WE CAN HELP
EACH OTHER OUT WITH INTERVIEWS,
SCREENING HAVING ONE JOB POSTING
30 JOBS AVAILABLE AND FIGURING
THAT PROCESS OUT. WE CAN DO THAT
TOGETHER. UM AND I'M GONNA BE
PILOTING THAT MY TEAM IS GONNA
BE ASSISTING ME. WE'RE GONNA BE
TRYING THAT OUT TO SEE IF IT
WORKS. CALPERS HAS DONE RAPID
HIRING EVENTS WHERE THEY HIRED.
THEY GOT 600 PEOPLE AND THEY
WERE ABLE TO FILL ALL THEIR
POSITIONS. EVEN Kò HÌ R DID THAT
AS WELL. SO IT IS POSSIBLE WE
HAVE TO GET TOGETHER AND TALK
ABOUT THINGS AND STOP MAKING
THINGS SO COMPLEX WHEN THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE AGAIN TO YOUR
POINT. SENATOR STICKING TO THE
PARAMETERS AND LOOKING AT
INNOVATION AND HOW WE CAN DO
THIS IN THE ONE PROBLEM WITH
HAVING A CAREER. THAT'S DECADES
LONG AS YOU KNOW THAT EVERY
PROPOSAL LIKE THAT HAS
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE. AND SO
IF I AM ABLE TO MOVE REALLY
QUICKLY FOR THREE VACANCIES AND
ONE AGENCY, AND NOW I HAVE TO
WAIT FOR A PROCESS THAT DOES 20
AGENCIES IN THIS 30. YOU HAVE TO
FIGHT WITH THE LIST FOR OTHER
PEOPLE AND GET OFF. I DON'T KNOW
THAT THAT WOULD WORK FOR ME. SO
HE HE I. I CAN FEEL THE, UH,
STARE OF THE CHAIR, SO I'M NOT
GONNA CON CONTINUE MUCH LONGER.
BUT YOU PICK UP THAT THAT WE
WANT THIS TO WORK AND WE WANT TO
ATTACK THIS VACANCY LEVEL. WE
WANT TO KNOW IF ANYTHING IS
NEEDED FROM US TO BE PARTNERS IN
DOING THAT, AND THAT'S THE
IMPORTANT THING. AND IF AND YOU
SEE SOMETIMES BECAUSE YOU TALKED
ABOUT 20,000 POSITIONS BEING
ADDED, I SUSPECT THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE AROUND THIS DÍAS THAT
HAVE PARTICIPATED IN THE REASON
YOU HAVE EXTRA POSITIONS. WE
NEED TO KNOW THAT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO ASK. CAN THIS BE
ACCOMPLISHED QUICKLY IF WE
REALLY ARE GOING TO START
MARCHING DOWN THAT PATH, SO IT
IS REALLY SOMETHING WE'RE GONNA
WANNA TALK ABOUT. PERFECT AND
I'M GONNA STOP THERE. I COULD GO
ON ABOUT OTHER STUFF, BUT I'M
GONNA STOP. OK THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
RESPOND. REALLY GOOD SENATOR
LAIRD. THANK YOU FOR THAT. I
THINK YOU WERE TALKING FOR ALL
OF US IN WHAT WE'RE THINKING, SO
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. MY TURN.
LET'S GO OVER TO LEADER JONES,
PLEASE. THANK YOU. JUST JUST A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS IN RESPONSE
TO SENATOR LÀ AND SENATOR GROVE
ON THE ON THE 20% VACANCY RATE.
YOU KNOW, MAYBE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE LOOK AT IS AN AND
MAYBE THIS IS ALREADY DONE AND I
DON'T KNOW. DO WE NEED ALL OF
THOSE VACANCIES AND IN A TIME OF
BUDGET DEFICITS, IS IT POSSIBLE
IN SOME OF THESE DEPARTMENTS TO,
YOU KNOW, TEMPORARILY OR
PERMANENTLY ELIMINATE SOME OF
THOSE POSITIONS BECAUSE WE DON'T
NEED THEM. I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
ANALYSIS HAS BEEN DONE ON ANY OF
THESE DEPARTMENTS, WOULD YOU BE
ABLE TO KNOW THAT TODAY OR I
WOULD NOT SIR, AND THAT PROBABLY
WOULD BE SOMETHING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, I WOULD THINK WOULD
HAVE TO KIND OF TAKE A LOOK AT
AND THAT'S KIND OF WHAT I
THOUGHT AND THEN ON ON A SENATOR
GROVES COMMENTS AS SOMEBODY WHO
BARELY GRADUATED FROM COLLEGE.
UH BUT I DO HAVE A BUSINESS
DEGREE IN HUMAN RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT. NEVER WORKED IN THAT
PART OF THE MANAGEMENT. UH, BUT
GOT YOU KNOW, I DO HAVE A DEGREE
I. I UM, AGREE THAT REMOVING THE
DEGREE REQUIREMENT FROM MANY OF
THESE POSITIONS IS A GOOD WAY TO
GO. UH, WE'RE WATCHING
NATIONWIDE. MAJOR EMPLOYERS, UM
COAST TO COAST. REMOVE THOSE
REQUIREMENTS AND I COLLEGE ISN'T
FOR EVERYBODY. I LIKE I SAID, I
BARELY GOT THROUGH IT. UM BUT I,
YOU KNOW, I. I KNOW LOTS OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE A LOT SMARTER
THAN ME THAT DIDN'T GO TO
COLLEGE AND ARE VERY CAPABLE.
AND UM SO, I. I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THAT I AGREE WITH THAT
MOVEMENT IN THAT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR
LEADER. ANYTHING ELSE? SENATOR
LAIRD. SURE. YOU HAD TO ASK HIM
TWICE. IT USED TO BE WITH REGARD
TO SENATOR JOHN'S QUESTION. I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THE CURRENT
ROLE IS. BUT IF THERE'S A
VACANCY FOR A CERTAIN PERIOD OF
TIME, THAT'S UNFILLED. THE
POSITION GETS SWEPT. IS THAT
STILL IN? THAT IS NOT THE
PROCESS ANYMORE. GOOD BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE HAULING ALL THESE
VACANCIES, THINGS ARE GONNA GET
SWEPT JUST BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
FILL THE POSITION. UM, THE OTHER
QUESTION THEN, SINCE I WAS
SUGGESTED, IS HOW DO YOU DEAL
WITH INEQUITIES? AND WHAT IS
YOUR PROCESS BECAUSE, FOR
EXAMPLE, THE SCIENTISTS AT
DIFFERENT TIMES WE HAD A PROBLEM
WHEN I WAS SECRETARY, WHERE THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE SUPERVISING
SOME PEOPLE WERE GETTING PAID
LESS THAN THEM. BECAUSE THEY
WERE DIFFERENT UNITS AND THERE
WAS INEQUITY AND THERE WAS AN
ATTEMPT TO FIX IT, UH, OVER TIME
, AND IT WAS TAKING FOREVER. THE
GREAT RECESSION POSTPONED IT
BECAUSE THERE WASN'T MONEY, BUT
IT KEPT US IN EQUITY GOING ON.
HOW DO YOU REGULARLY LOOK TO
MAKE SURE INEQUITIES LIKE THAT
ARE NOT GONNA EXIST AND YOU'RE
GONNA TAKE A SHOT AT FIXING IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTION. UM, WE DO HAVE AN
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION PROCESS.
SO DEPARTMENTS ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO BRING THIS TO TENSION. WHEN
THEY BRING IT TO OUR ATTENTION.
WE TAKE A LOOK AT OK IS THERE AN
INEQUITY ISSUE GOING ON? IS
THERE SOMEBODY MAKING A MORE
THAN THE OTHER? I DON'T WANT TO
GET TOO TECHNICAL ON THIS, BUT
THE CLASS PLAN AT KELLY CHAR.
TIES ALL OF THESE
CLASSIFICATIONS TOGETHER SO, FOR
EXAMPLE, IF YOU HAVE CERTAIN
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT REPORT UP
TO A SUPERVISOR AND THEN AND
THEN YOU HAVE OTHER POSITIONS
THAT KIND OF DO THE SAME WORK.
THERE'S THIS BIG GIANT CHART
THAT SHOWS ALL THESE
CLASSIFICATION RELATIONSHIPS.
I'LL CALL THEM. SO WE TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT EVERY TIME WE GO
THROUGH A BARGAINING PROCESS.
AND WE MAKE SURE THAT CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN, UH IN
THAT SAME HORIZONTAL TAK, I'LL
CALL IT GETS PAY RAISES. SO WHEN
WE HAVE A PAY RAISE THAT
HAPPENS, UM, HOWEVER, IF THERE
IS AN INEQUITY IDENTIFIED, THERE
IS A PROCESS THAT WILL GO
THROUGH WHERE OUR EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION UNIT WILL DO AN
ANALYSIS AND SEE IF IT IS AN
ACCURATE STATEMENT, THEY WILL
LOOK AT A VARIETY OF THINGS.
MAYBE COMPARING TO THE LABOR
CURRENT LABOR MARKET. ARE WE NOT
PAYING THEM? UM APPROPRIATELY TO
WHAT'S OUT THERE IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR, AND WE'RE LOSING PEOPLE
FOR THAT. AND THEN IF THAT
PERSON GETS A PAY INCREASE, WE
LOOK AT EVERYBODY ELSE. WE ALSO
HAVE A, UM WHAT KELLY CHAR IS
WORKING ON ALSO IS A DASHBOARDS
DASHBOARDS FOR MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT COULD INCLUDE
COMPOSITION OF THE WORKFORCE AND
ALSO LOOKING AT PAY EQUITY
ISSUES AS WELL. SO IF WE TAKE
THIS TWO COMMENTS, AND ONE IS
THAT WE HAD A HISTORIC PAY AND
EQUITY WITH REGARD TO EMPLOYEES
OF THE WATER PROJECT. AND WE
PAID LOWER THAN ALL, UH,
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT ALL
THESE COMPARABLE WATER DISTRICTS
AND AS A RESULT, WE WERE HIRING
AN ENTRY LEVEL TRAINING THEM AND
THEY WERE ALL GETTING HIGHER.
UH, HIGHER PAY AND MOVING ON,
AND THAT WAS ADDRESSED IT IT
FINALLY THERE WERE IT MADE THE
NEWSPAPERS BECAUSE PEOPLE
THOUGHT IT WAS AN INEQUITY TO
ADDRESS IT OUT OF SYNC. BUT IT
ADDRESSED THAT ISSUE. I JUST
WONDER BECAUSE THE SCIENTISTS
SEEMS TO HAVE GONE ON FOR A LONG
AMOUNT OF TIME. AND SO IF YOU'VE
GOT THIS CHART AND YOU LOOK AND
YOU GO THROUGH MULTIPLE
NEGOTIATIONS. HOW COULD IT NOT
BE ADDRESSED THAT PEOPLE IN ONE
UNIT WOULD BE GETTING PAID LESS
THAN THE PEOPLE THEY'RE
SUPERVISING IN ANOTHER UNIT? HOW
COULD THAT NOT BE ADDRESSED OVER
TIME? SO I WOULD SAY, UM, IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
SCIENTISTS, UM, WELL, YOU KNOW,
NEGOTIATIONS ARE VERY COMPLEX AS
WE ARE GOING THROUGH. I KNOW IF
YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF THEM,
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SO WHAT I CAN SAY
IS MM. WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
LABOUR NEGOTIATIONS CAN BE
CONTENTIOUS AS WE'RE GOING
THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND THE
DIRECTOR OF Kò, HÌ, R AND THE
CHIEF OF LABOR CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS ISSUE THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO IN PARTICULAR, UM I
WILL JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT. OK
THANK YOU. NOTE THAT THE CONCERN
IS THERE ON THIS SIDE NOTED,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR,
I. I NÓ YOU'RE REGRETTING HAVING
NÓ NOT AT ALL. VERY GRATEFUL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR LAIRD
. ALL RIGHT. WHAT WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO DO IS NOW OPEN UP.
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR MADAM CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. WE WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO START TO SEE IF
THERE IS ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
MADAM CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
PLEASE COME TO THE PODIUM AT
THIS TIME. WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD THIS TIME.
THIS WILL BE LAST CALL FOR
SUPPORT. OH, GOOD AFTERNOON. IF
YOU COULD PLEASE STATE YOUR
FIRST AND LAST NAME AND THE
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH. WE
WELCOME YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS MIA VEGA.
I'M DEPUTY DIRECTOR, STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS AND PLANNING AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE,
ACCESS AND INFORMATION. I HAD
THE PLEASURE OF, UM, WORKING
ALONGSIDE MISS ERICKSON. WHEN I
WAS APPOINTED TO MY TO MY ROLE,
AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK, UM, ABOUT
MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE OF, UH,
WORKING WITH HER AS A LEADER OF
THE ORGANIZATION AND ALSO, UH,
ABOUT, UH, MY EXPERIENCE, UH,
COMING INTO THIS, UH,
MAGNIFICENT. UH, JOB THAT I HAVE
THE PRIVILEGED TO SERVE THE GOOD
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND SEEING
A LATINA IN A, UH, LEADERSHIP
POSITION. WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT
TO ABOUT 30 SECONDS, PLEASE. SO
I, I HAVE NÓ I'M NÓ. NÓ DOUBT
AND VERY CONFIDENT IN THE M.
ERIC'S UH, PROCESS, UH, ABILITY
TO INNOVATE OR PROCESS. IT IS A
VERY CUMBERSOME PROCESS. UM BUT
I'M WHAT I'M MOST EXCITED ABOUT.
HER LEADERSHIP IS HER PROVEN
ABILITY TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
STRATEGIES THAT WILL PRIORITIZE
STRATEGIC SOURCING TO INCREASE
THE CANDIDATE POOL. THAT IS
ULTIMATELY GOING TO RESULT IN
DIVERSIFYING THE STATE WORKFORCE
, SO IT'S REFLECTIVE OF THE
DIVERSE IN THE STATE. SO I'M
EXCITED ABOUT THAT. I THINK IT'S
A GOAL THAT SHOULD WE SHOULD ALL
BE WORKING HARD TO DO. THAT'LL
BE ALL, SIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR BAKER. WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU. WE'D LIKE
TO WELCOME ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO COMMENT
TODAY. IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
WE LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU AGAIN, MISS VEGA.
WE'RE GONNA LOOK FOR THOSE WHO
MAY BE IN OPPOSITION IF HE COULD
COME FORWARD AT THIS TIME, WE
ARE LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION. WE'RE GONNA DO A
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE GONNA BRING
YOU BACK TO COMMITTEE GRATEFUL
THAT YOU ARE HERE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME AND FOR
YOUR WORK, AND LET'S JUST BE
REALLY HONEST ABOUT IT, UM, ONE
OF THE MOST CHALLENGING JOBS IN
STATE SERVICE, UH, IN GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR FOCUS AND YOUR TENACITY
AND REALLY EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO
SEE THAT CAMPAIGN GOING OUT TO
BE ABLE TO BRING FOLKS INTO
STATE SERVICE TO HELP BUILD A
STRONGER CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE. WE'RE
GONNA BE NOW ASKING A COMMITTEE
FOR A MOTION, PLEASE. YOU'RE
GONNA ASK THE ENTIRE COMMITTEE.
A MOTION. THERE WE GO. YES I
WOULD MOVE THAT CONFIRMATION OF
MS ERIC. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
SENATOR LAIRD. MADAM SECRETARY,
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE CALL THE
ROLL? AYE. MAGUIRE A GROVE. EGM.
JONES LAIRD LAIRD, I ON CALL.
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ON CALL.
THAT IS A 20 VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND
FOR TAKING THE TIME. THANK YOU.
WE'LL ADD THOSE FOLKS ON AS THEY
COME BACK IN. PERFECT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. SENATOR LAIRD. I LOOK
FORWARD TO TALKING TO YOU ABOUT
A 10% VACANCY. THERE WE GO.
WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN. I THINK WE
MAY NEED A TWO MINUTE BREAK. ALL
RIGHT, A FIVE MINUTE. YES WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A FIVE MINUTE RECESS.
FIVE MINUTE RECESS WILL BE
COMING BACK HERE. UH, HANG
TIGHT, FIVE MINUTE RECESS.
ALL RIGHT, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL
THAT YOU HAVE STUCK WITH US.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON
TO ITEM ONE. Dð. THIS IS THE
POTENTIAL APPOINTMENT. DEPUTY
SECRETARY TRESKIN. MADAM DEPUTY
SECRETARY, IF YOU WANNA COME ON
UP, WE WELCOME YOU, UH, TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE TODAY AND
HANGING WITH US AS WE LOOK AT
THE OTHER APPOINTEES, MADAM
DEPUTY SECRETARY HAVE ABOUT A
MINUTE OR TWO TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TO THE
COMMITTEE. WE WILL THEN OPEN IT
UP TO MEMBERS FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS THAT THEY MAY HAVE
OF WE WOULD LOVE IT IF WE WOULD
WELCOME ANY AND OUR GUEST FAMILY
, FRIENDS, COWORKERS WHO ARE
WITH YOU TODAY, IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU HAVE A GROUP AND WE ARE, UH
THE BAND IS READY TO GO. MY
GOODNESS. UH, IT'S WONDERFUL
THAT THEY'RE HERE TODAY. UH, AND
IT MEANS A LOT TO US. WE'LL BE
KEEPING TIME OF YOUR OPENING.
WHEN YOU HIT ABOUT 30. SECONDS
TOWARDS THAT TWO MINUTES, WE'LL
GIVE YOU A HEADS UP AND AGAIN,
NOT AT ALL. TRYING TO BE RUDE
AND VICTORY. SECRETARY AT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AND WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. UM I'M
VERY GRATEFUL TO BE HERE ALSO,
UM, SO THANK YOU. AND GOOD
AFTERNOON PRO TIM MCGUIRE AND
SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE. I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME TODAY, UM I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR
TRUSTING ME WITH THIS IMPORTANT
ROLE. I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE TO LABOR SECRETARY
KNOX UNDER SECRETARY ROBERTS AND
MY TEAM FROM THE LABOR AGENCY
FOR THEIR SUPPORT HERE TODAY.
UM, MY FRIENDS, MENTORS AND
MEMBERS OF MY KITCHEN CABINET
FROM CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AS WELL AS TO MY
FRIENDS AND FAMILY WATCHING FROM
HOME. I COULDN'T BE MORE
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR PRESENCE HERE
TODAY. UM I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY DAUGHTER JOHANNA,
A HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR, AND SHE'S
MY BRIGHT LIGHT. UM I'M
EMBARRASSING HER. MY SON, DARIS
IS HERE. HE'S A RECENT COLLEGE
GRADUATE. AND UM, WE ARE SO
PROUD OF HIM AND MY MAMA SHARON,
UH, IS HERE. SHE'S MY HERO. UH,
SHE WENT TO LAW SCHOOL AS A
SINGLE MOM OF A FIVE YEAR OLD.
MY MOM'S DETERMINATION AND HER
COMMITMENT TO SOCIAL JUSTICE
HAVE INSPIRED ME DEEPLY. 1968
SHE WAS ONE OF THE FEW WOMEN
LEADERS IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
STATE COLLEGE STRIKE. THE
MOVEMENT THAT BIRTHED THE FIRST
DEPARTMENTS OF BLACK AND ETHNIC
STUDIES IN THE NATION. HER
LIFELONG DEDICATION TO EQUITY
HAS SHAPED MY PATH. NOW AS THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR STRATEGIC
PLANNING AND EQUITY. I'M FOCUSED
ON I'M FOCUSED ON EMBEDDING
EQUITY THROUGHOUT AGENCIES
OPERATIONS. WORKING IN A LABOR
UNION TAUGHT ME THE POWER OF
ORGANIZING TO BE ABLE TO ALIGN
PEOPLE AND SHIFT POWER. USING
ORGANIZING CONCEPTS. I'M WORKING
TO CREATE A CROSS AGENCY EQUITY
WORK GROUP TO STRATEGICALLY
COORDINATE EFFORTS AND LEAD
CHANGE IN INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL
PRACTICES. WE'VE CREATED AN
INTERNAL CULTURE COMMITTEE TO
REINFORCE TEAM UNITY, ULTIMATELY
CREATING A SYNERGY THAT DIRECTLY
INFLUENCES OUR WORK. WE'RE
REIMAGINING THE WAY THAT WE
COMMUNICATE ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS ON OUR WEB PAGE, AND
WHEN WE ADDRESS THE PUBLIC, THIS
IS AN EFFORT TO DEEPEN OUR
CONNECTION WITH AN INTEREST.
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE. I'M
LEADING THE WORK ON DEVELOPING
OUR STRATEGIC PLAN CENTERING.
ENSURING EQUITY CENTERED
ALIGNMENT THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
. UM I'M PROUD TO LEAD WITH
PRINCIPLES THAT PRIORITIZE
EQUITY AND EMPOWERMENT IN OUR
ROOTED IN THE PURSUIT OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE. I HOPE THAT I EARN YOUR
SUPPORT, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. AND DEPUTY SECRETARY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. IT IS SO SPECIAL TO
HAVE YOUR MOM HERE. SHARON MY
GOODNESS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JOHANNA AND DARIS WELCOME. WE'RE
REALLY HAPPY THAT YOU'RE HERE.
MY GOODNESS. UM WE'RE GONNA OPEN
IT UP, UH, TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS, COMMENTS OR
CONVERSATIONS, BUT WHY DON'T WE
START WITH MADAM VICE CHAIR?
MADAM VICE CHAIR OF THE FLOOR
RESOURCE, PLEASE. THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR. I WAS THINKING MY
COLLEAGUE WANTED TO GO FIRST.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MA'AM. FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. I APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK YOU'VE DONE IN THE PAST. I
DO. I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS. IT'S A STRATEGICALLY
JUST FOR MY DISTRICT. I KNOW.
THE GOVERNOR HAS ANNOUNCED HIS
$26 MILLION GRANTS TO PREPARE
FOR DISPLACED WORKERS IN THE OIL
AND GAS INDUSTRY SECTORS. MANY
OF THAT 70% OF THE STATE'S OIL
COMES FROM MY DISTRICT, SO A
VERY IMPORTANT SUBJECT MATTER
FOR THEM FOR ME AND THEM, UH
THEY PROMISED TO DO RETRAINING
FOR RENEWABLE TECHNOLOGY JOBS.
WE PRODUCE 50 THREE PERCENT. DO
YOU WANT TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION? IT. OH, DEAR LORD 53%
OF THE STATE'S RENEWABLE ENERGY
ALSO COMES FROM MY DISTRICT, AND
THERE'S A PROMISE TO RETAIN OUR
OIL INDUSTRY, INDIVIDUALS IN
NANOTECHNOLOGY AND OTHER AREAS.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO MAKE
ROUGHLY $100,000 A YEAR, THEIR
SECOND CHANCES. THEY'RE PEOPLE
AT 55% PEOPLE OF COLOR 46%
PEOPLE SECOND CHANCES RIGHT
BECAUSE WE CAN TEACH SOMEBODY A
SKILL IN THE TRADE IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY, AS LONG AS WE CAN HAVE
THEM HAVE THE SOFT SKILLS TO
SHOW UP. SO THIS IS A VITAL
INDUSTRY FOR REC CITIZEN.
REDUCTION IT IS A VITAL INDUSTRY
FOR DOMESTIC SECURITY. AND MY
QUESTION IS, UM WE'RE GOING TO
SPEND ABOUT $25 BILLION FOR
COUNTRIES TO IMPORT THE OIL WE
USE EVERY SINGLE DAY. UM WE ARE
GOING TO BRING OIL IN FROM
ECUADOR. SAUDI ARABIA. WOMEN CAN
DRIVE. THEY CAN'T VOTE. ECUADOR
BULLDOZED DOWN THE AMERICAN, THE
WORLD'S LUNG IN THE RAINFOREST,
AND, UM WE HAVE OUR OWN 2045
SCOPING PLAN FOR A 2% REDUCTION,
WHICH IS NOT UNDER YOUR PURVIEW,
BUT WE ARE NOT EVEN STICKING TO
THAT. BUT YOU ARE WITH THE
STRATEGIC PLANNING ON EQUITY AND
EQUITY. UH WE HAVE 12% WOMEN 46%
2ND CHANCES AND 55% PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN THE OIL INDUSTRY AND
THAT IS A BIG DEAL. AND WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT, I DON'T NEED
ANOTHER $15 AN HOUR AMAZON
FACILITY IN MY DISTRICT. I WANT
REAL JOBS IF YOU'RE GOING TO
TAKE AWAY THE OIL INDUSTRY AND
RELY ON DOMESTIC RELY ON FOREIGN
NATIONS TO PROVIDE US THE ENERGY
. WE NEED EVERY SINGLE DAY TO
SURVIVE IN THE STATE. WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO DO WITH MY PEOPLE
THAT ARE LOSING THEIR JOBS EVERY
SINGLE DAY? BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
EVEN FOLLOWING OUR 2045 SCOPING
PLAN THAT WAS DEVELOPED BY THIS
BODY AND THIS GOVERNOR. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. I KNOW THAT WAS
LOVE TO NOT HOST NÓ. I GET IT. I
GET IT. FIGHT FOR YOUR PEOPLE.
OK UM SO, SO NÓ. I TOTALLY GET
IT. UM AND LET ME JUST SAY SO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION. I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERNS. UM, I WANNA TELL YOU
THAT, UM WE ARE COMMITTED TO, UM
, TO READ LIKE YOU LIKE YOU
MENTIONED. RETRAINING THE FOLKS,
UM, THAT MAY LOSE. UM, THESE
HIGH PAYING POSITIONS INTO, UM
POSITIONS LIKE POSITIONS OR,
LIKE PAY POSITIONS. UM, WE'RE
COMMITTING TO TRADE. WE'RE
COMMITTED TO TRAINING THEM. AS
YOU MENTIONED. THERE'S BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN THAT
REGARD. UM YOU KNOW, IN A REGION
LIKE HER IN COUNTY, UM WE ARE
WORKING WITH, UM, OUR ASSISTANT
DEPUTY OF CLIMATE ECONOMY IS
WORKING WITH GOBI TO SUPPORT
LOCAL PARTNERS, UM, IN
IDENTIFYING NEW AND EMERGING
SECTORS SO WE CAN REPLACE THESE
GOOD HOT GOOD. HIGH PAYING JOBS.
UM, SO SPECIFIC TO KERN COUNTY,
THE GOVERNOR AND DO ALL THE
LEGISLATURE, UM, HAVE ALSO
INVESTED IN PROGRAMS AS YOU
MENTIONED, UM TO SUPPORT
DISPLACED GAS AND OIL WORKERS.
UM AND WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
WORKING, UM, IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED. UM
THERE IS ANOTHER. THERE'S
ANOTHER THING I WANT TO MENTION,
AND THAT'S THE CALIFORNIA JOBS
FIRST INITIATIVE. WHILE THIS
ISN'T NECESSARILY SPECIFIC TO,
UM, TO KERN, YOU KNOW BROADLY
REACHES CALIFORNIANS IN SIMILAR
SITUATIONS. IT IS A FOCUS THAT
WE HAVE, UM THERE IS AND THE
REGIONAL INVESTMENT INITIATIVE.
UM, WHERE THERE IS FUNDING
PROVIDED, UM, AGAIN IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO MORE BROAD CALIFORNIANS, UM,
IN SIMILAR SITUATIONS, SO I
GUESS I JUST WANNA LEAVE WITH
YOU THAT THIS IS A THIS IS A
FOCUS. WE HEAR YOU. WE GET IT.
UM YEAH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ANSWERING THAT
QUESTION. I AM. YOU KNOW, AS A
DEPUTY SECRETARY, ONE OF THE
DUTIES IS THAT YOU ARE ENGAGED
IN THE COMMUNITY AND YOU ENGAGE
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES THAT'S
GOING ON. HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO
KERN COUNTY IN THE OIL INDUSTRY?
I HAVE NOT BEEN TO I WOULD LOVE
TO GO. I HAVE NOT BEEN TO
CURRENT CAVE BEEN TO KERN
COUNTY, NOT THE OIL INDUSTRY.
I'VE BEEN FIRE YOU TO MEET SOME
OF THE CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT LOSING
THEIR JOB TOMORROW. UM LIKE I
SAID, UM, I COULD INTRODUCE YOU
TO PEOPLE LIKE JERRY FLORES OR
OTHERS THAT YOU KNOW HIS STORY.
YOU KNOW PELICAN BAY SPEND A
DIME UP THERE IN A NICKEL
SOMEPLACE ELSE. AND HE IS, UM HE
NOW HAS A HOUSE IN THE BACK OF
HIS HOUSE. WHERE HIS MOM, YOU
KNOW, HIS MOM USED TO GET READY,
YOU KNOW, DO GET THE FAMILY
TOGETHER FOR BAIL MONEY. AND NOW
HE HAS A AN A Dð U IN THE BACK
OF HIS HOUSE, SO HIS MOM HAS A
PLACE TO LIVE WITH THE GRANDKIDS
AND HE IS VERY FILIAL ABOUT
LOSING HIS JOB. THERE ARE
SEVERAL PEOPLE LIKE THAT. UM UH,
THAT YOU KNOW, UH, AGAIN, NOT IN
YOUR PURVIEW. BUT IF WE WOULD
JUST STICK TO THE 2045 PLAN THAT
WAS PUT TOGETHER BY THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY IN THIS
GOVERNOR AND THE èC èC AND THE
èC PU èC. WE WOULD NOT HAVE
THIS DISCUSSION AND PROBLEMS
BECAUSE WE WOULD DECLINE IN OUR
DOMESTIC PRODUCTION BY 2%
INSTEAD OF 10% AND WHEN I THINK
AND AGAIN NOT UNDER YOUR PURVIEW
, BUT JUST BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
WE'RE ON TELEVISION, AND I CAN
SAY THIS IS, UM I THINK WHEN THE
WHEN WE ALL REALIZE THAT WE'RE
GONNA NEED THIS, THE STRUCTURE
IS GOING TO BE GONE, AND IT'S
GOING TO BE IMPOSSIBLE TO
REBUILD WITH REFINERIES LEAVING
THE STATE. SO, UM, I WOULD
REALLY LIKE YOUR ATTENTION
FOCUSED ON THIS. I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU ARE FOCUSING ON THIS
AND LIKE I SAID, I WANT EQUITY
ACROSS THE BOARD. I WANT
EQUALITY ACROSS THE BOARD. IF
THEY'RE MAKING $100,000 I DON'T
WANT THEM GOING TO AMAZON FOR 15
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T RAISE THEIR
KIDS ON THAT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. THE ADVICE WE GO
TO SENATOR EGM LAIRD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND THANK YOU AND
WELCOME. UH, IT'S GREAT TO HAVE
YOUR ENTIRE FAMILY HERE OF THREE
GENERATIONS HAS VERY NICE. AND
UH, JUST MY COLLEAGUE, UH, FROM
KN COUNTY WHO MAKES FUN OF ME
BECAUSE I DRIVE AN ELECTRIC CAR
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT THAT
ECUADORIAN GAS. I JUST DON'T. UM
UH SO I JUST WANNA KNOW SO YOU
YOU YOU ARE WORKING ON
DEVELOPING MINI PLANS AS PART OF
YOUR PURVIEW. UM TELL ME THEN
HOW DO YOU HOW? WHAT ARE KIND OF
METRICS DO YOU USE SUCCESS. HOW
DO WE KNOW WE'RE GETTING TO
WHERE WE WANT TO BE? UM, A LOT
OF THESE THINGS CAN JUST FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE KIND OF A REFORMING
THEY'RE OUT THERE. HOW DO WE
KNOW WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS ON
ANY OF THEM? AND THAT THAT
PROGRESS IS THE PLACE. WE WANT
TO GO, RIGHT? SURE SURE, SURE.
SO, SO I THINK YOU KNOW AT THIS
POINT. I THINK AT THIS POINT, UM
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT THE I
HAVE TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
SPECIFIC TO A PROJECT, YOU KNOW.
SO FOR INSTANCE, IN THE
STRATEGIC PLAN, WE ARE GOING TO
BE DE DEVELOP. WE'RE IN. WE'RE
IN THE ST WITHIN THE STRATEGIC
PLAN. WE'RE CREATING AN EQUITY
ACTION PLAN, AND WE'RE GONNA
DEVELOP A MATRIX SPECIFICALLY
FOR THAT RIGHT? AND THAT'S UH
COMPARED TO THE EQUITY WORK
ACROSS AGENCY EQUITY WORK GROUP
WHERE WE WILL BE MEETING WITH
ALL THE EQUITY FOLKS FROM ACROSS
THE, UM THE AGENCY AND TALKING
ABOUT YOU KNOW, POLICIES
PROCEDURES THE WAY THAT WE
COMMUNICATE WITH THE PUBLIC AND
CREATING POLICY WILL BE ABLE TO
SEE HOW HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
ENGAGING. YOU KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE FEEL COMFORTABLE WHERE
ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS YOU KNOW
TO ASK THEM? WHAT IS IT? YOU
NEED CENTERING THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE MOST AFFECTED, YOU KNOW, SO
I THINK THAT THAT'S GONNA BE
WHEN WE WHEN IT COMES TO THAT
PLACE WHEN IT'S TIME TO, YOU
KNOW, UH, I GUESS WEIGH THE
METRICS. UM THE VOICES OF THE
PEOPLE MOST AFFECTED WILL BE
CENTERED AND WILL HELP TO GUIDE
US IN THAT, YOU KNOW, I DON'T I
DON'T WANT TO GIVE YOU AN ANSWER
. THAT SOUNDS GOOD RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE KIND OF
PHONY TO ME, YOU KNOW? SO I
THINK THAT THAT'S IT. THAT'S A
LOT OF A LOT OF OUR WORK IS
DEFINITELY JUST GONNA CENTER ON
THE PEOPLE MOST AFFECTED AND I'D
LOVE TO GET BACK TO YOU OK?
GREAT METRIC SET, EVEN IF IT'S
QUALITATIVE AND QUANTITATIVE,
RIGHT? LIKE WHAT IS THE GOAL.
AND HOW DO WE KNOW WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS TO GET THERE? RIGHT SO
JUST SOME KIND OF ONGOING
EVALUATION, I THINK FOR ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT TASK FORCES IS
ABSOLUTELY ONGOING EVALUATION IS
CENTERED IN IT. SO UM, YOU KNOW,
IT'S JUST I THINK I GUESS THE
WAY I WAS THINKING ABOUT IT WAS.
WHAT DOES THAT EVALUATION LOOK
LIKE? BECAUSE IT'S GONNA LOOK
DIFFERENT, RIGHT FOR EACH
PROGRAM. UM SO, YES, THANK YOU.
OK, AS LONG AS LONG AS WE KEEP
IN THE FOREFRONT OF OUR MIND, I
THINK RIGHT OUR ROAD MAP LIKE,
WHERE ARE WE TRYING TO GET? AND
HOW DO WE KNOW WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS? AND WHEN DO WE KNOW
WHEN WE GET THERE? RIGHT?
EXACTLY. AND I JUST ALSO WANT TO
ADD TO THAT THE IMPORTANCE OF,
UM WHILE WE'RE WHILE WE'RE
WATCHING, YOU KNOW WHERE OUR
PROGRAM GOES THE IMPORTANCE OF
BEING ABLE TO PIVOT IF WE ARE,
IF WE FEEL LIKE WE'RE GOING IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BE AGILE, SO
AGILITY WILL BE BUILT INTO ANY
PLAN OR ANY, UM, ANY ANY PROGRAM
THAT WE RUN. YEAH, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SENATOR
LATER, PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MISTER CHAIR. UM, FIRST
OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT IS
IMPRESSIVE. AND THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE I REALLY VALUE THAT ARE
IN YOUR SUPPORTERS. SO THAT
SPEAKS VOLUMES AND, UM AND I
APPRECIATE IT A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS IN IN THE FIRST ONE
IS, UM, I. I SPENT EIGHT YEARS
DOING WHAT STEWART DOES, AND
THERE WERE BECAUSE I NOTICED
THAT THERE WAS ONE SUBJECT OR
QUESTION IN HERE ABOUT HOW TO
ENGAGE EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP. IN
ON THESE ISSUES TO MAKE SURE IT
HAPPENS. I DIDN'T BELIEVE IN
HAVING DEPARTMENT HEAD MEETINGS
BECAUSE EVERYBODY GRANDSTANDED
AND I PREFER TO DO ONE ON ONE
MEETINGS WITH THE DEPARTMENT,
BUT IN THE EIGHT YEARS I HAD 21
WAS BECAUSE ONE DEPARTMENT HAD
FALLEN DOWN ON ME, TOO. ISSUES
IN A WAY THAT I WANTED EVERYBODY
TO KNOW THIS WAS A PRIORITY OF
THE AGENCY AND WE WERE NOT GOING
TO DO SOME PRETTY WEIRD THINGS
THAT HAD HAPPENED AND THIS WAS
BEFORE THE NATIONAL ME TOO, SO
THAT I COULD LOOK EVERYBODY'S
EYE AND GET THEM KNOW THE SECOND
ONE WAS ON TRIBAL ISSUES BECAUSE
THAT HAD BEEN ANOTHER ISSUE
WHERE I WANTED EVERYBODY TO KNOW
AND EVERYBODY TO DO IT AND
INTEGRATE IT. HOW DO YOU SEE
ENGAGING WITH EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP ON THESE ISSUES SO
THAT THEY DON'T THINK IT'S SOME
PROFORMA THING THAT THEY REALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY HAVE TO
ENGAGE AND THAT THE TWO OF YOU
HAVE A PATH TO DO IT THAT IT'S
NOT JUST HEY, DO THIS AND HAVE
YOUR ARMS FOLDED AND JUDGE THEM.
IT'S LIKE, HOW DO YOU DO YOU
TOGETHER? DO THIS, SO THEY
INCULCATE IT AND FEEL LIKE
THERE'S A PARTNERSHIP IN DOING
IT. SURE, SURE. SO, UM, I'LL
TELL YOU SO JUST I WANNA I GUESS
A LITTLE STORY TIME. SO YOU KNOW
, COME. I WAS PICKED THE RIGHT,
RIGHT. RIGHT. SO UM, SO, UM, I
WAS AT CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS FOR 20 YEARS AND I
REMEMBER THEY USED TO ALWAYS SAY
, YOU KNOW, WE TRY TO MIMIC THE
FEELING THE CULTURE OF THE FIRE
SERVICE AT CPF IN THE IN THE
UNION. RIGHT AND I WAS LIKE, OH,
THAT SOUNDS NICE. DIDN'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANT, HOWEVER,
COMING OUT OF THE, UM OUT OF èC
PF. I SEE WHAT THOSE VALUES WERE
, AND THAT WAS COLLABORATION.
RIGHT? IT'S LIKE WITH EVERYBODY
AT THE TABLE AND GETTING EVERY
LEVEL OF BUY IN FROM THE LEADER
RIGHT DOWN TO THE RECEPTIONIST,
BECAUSE EVERYBODY HAS A PART AND
YOU NEED EVERYBODY'S ROLE IN
ORDER FOR WHATEVER IT IS TO
WORK. RIGHT SO, UM, I THINK TWO
TO YOUR TO YOUR QUESTIONS,
SENATOR LAIRD, UM, THE WAY THAT
I GO ABOUT ENGAGING LEADERSHIP,
I THINK IS, YOU KNOW, STARTING
OFF WITH A PLAN AND KNOWING
KNOWING MY KNOWING THE VISION OF
MY LEADERSHIP, YOU KNOW? UM,
WE'RE ALIGNED SO STARTING OFF
WITH A PLAN AND TALKING ABOUT
IT, YOU KNOW, AND HAVE BEING
ABLE TO HAVE REAL CONVERSATIONS
LIKE I'M SUPER BIG ON THAT. LIKE
IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT. TELL ME
TELL ME WHY. AND I MIGHT COME
BACK AND STILL TRY TO CONVINCE
YOU YOU KNOW, BUT YOU KNOW IT.
NOT SO I THINK THAT IS IT IS
HAVING CONVERSATION, UH, ABOUT
THE PLAN, AND GETTING THE BUY IN
THE BUY IN IS IMPERATIVE AND I
NOTICED THAT YOU. YOUR CABINET
SECRETARY THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT ENOUGH TO SIT HERE
DURING THIS HEARING. AND WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU HIT A STUMBLING
BLOCK IN TERMS OF ENGAGING HIM
IN BREAKING WHAT THAT MIGHT BE.
WELL I, I THINK. WELL IT
WOULDN'T BE. I MEAN, IT WOULDN'T
BE THE FIRST TIME I'VE NOT WITH
STEWART. I'M SORRY WITH THE
SECRETARY NOW WITH THE SECRETARY
, BUT I MEAN WITH A YOU KNOW,
WITH A WITH A LEADER WOULDN'T BE
THE FIRST TIME THAT YOU KNOW,
I'VE MAYBE BEEN TOLD NÓ. I THINK
I THINK IT DEPENDS ON ACTUALLY,
IT DEPENDS ON WHAT IT IS. YOU
KNOW, SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO BE
TENACIOUS AND COME BACK AND TRY
TO EXAMINE LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT
THE ISSUE IS, YOU KNOW, WHY ARE
YOU GETTING THE NÓ? UM YOU KNOW,
ANOTHER THING I LIKE TO SAY IS,
YOU KNOW I'LL COME UP WITH A
STRATEGY. AND I'M NOT
NECESSARILY COMMITTED TO HOW WE
GET THERE. I'M COMMITTED TO
BEING AT THAT PLACE. I'M
COMMITTED TO BEING AT THAT GOAL.
SO IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THE STRATEGY, OK, LET'S WORK
TOGETHER TO DEVELOP ANOTHER WAY
TO GET TO THE GOAL. NOW, IF
THERE'S AN ISSUE WITH THE GOAL,
THAT'S ANOTHER CONVERSATION, AND
I DON'T KNOW THAT, UM I'VE EVER
BEEN IN A PLACE WHERE I'VE HAD A
LEADER TELL ME THAT THEY WERE
AGAINST THE GOAL. I WAS TRYING
TO GET TO OK, WELL, HE DOES
THEIR EVALUATIONS AND YOU CAN
DEAL WITH THAT. IF THAT'S AN
ISSUE, I THINK THE OTHER THING
IS IN IN YOUR RESPONSES TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE QUESTIONS THERE
WAS IS SORT OF A CONSTANT THEME
ABOUT, UH, EQUITABLE ACCESS AND
QUALITY OUTCOMES FOR
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS, AND WE
CAN SEE IT IN YOUR PREVIOUS
ANSWERS TO THESE QUESTIONS. SORT
OF A SPECIFIC HERE IS SOMETHING
I AM SAW HERE SOMETHING I
DEVELOPED A POLICY. THIS IS
WHERE IT WENT SO THAT FOR THOSE
OF US THAT ARE SITTING HERE
TALKING ABOUT THIS? WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT MEANS. I
MEAN, WHERE YOU IDENTIFY THE
PROBLEM AND HOW YOU DEVELOP THE
STRATEGY. AND IF YOU HAVE TO
CHANGE THE SUBJECT TO PROTECT
THE INNOCENT OR SOMETHING, DO
THAT, BUT I THINK, UM, IT IT
WOULD BE OF INTEREST TO KNOW
JUST SORT OF A SPECIFIC WAY
YOU'VE ADDRESS AN ISSUE TO KNOW
FOR US TO LEARN THAT THAT'S HOW
YOU'VE DONE IT AND AN IMPORTANT
WAY TO DO IT. SURE SURE, SURE.
UM SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION, SENATOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT IT,
UM, TO TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW AN
ACTUAL POLICY OR OR MAYBE
PROGRAM, SOMETHING THAT I'VE
CREATED, UH, TO SOLVE AN ISSUE.
SO UM, THERE WAS, UM, AN
ORGANIZATION THAT I WAS WITH,
AND I REALIZED THAT WHICH WAS A
GREAT ORGANIZATION, YOU KNOW,
HAD A GREAT, UH GREAT MISSION.
GREAT PEOPLE, UM SMART PEOPLE.
HOWEVER FOLKS WERE KIND OF
SILOED. YOU KNOW, FOLKS WERE
KIND OF SILOED AND UM, AND
WEREN'T FEELING UM THEY WEREN'T
FEELING THE POWER OF
COLLABORATION. YOU KNOW? SO UM,
WHAT I DID IN THAT CASE WAS KIND
OF TALK TO FOLKS AND YOU KNOW
AND LEARN ABOUT THE SPACE AND
LEARN ABOUT LEARN A LOT ABOUT,
UM WHAT THE ORGANIZATION DID.
AND WITH THAT I CREATED, UM,
KIND OF A CLUB. KIND OF A CLUB
FOR PEOPLE TO JOIN THAT GÂY
FOLKS OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THINGS
THAT WERE MAYBE OUT OF THERE, UM
, OUT OF THEIR NORMAL DAY TO DAY
WORK, YOU KNOW, KIND OF LET
THEIR THEIR OTHER STARS SHINE.
UM YOU KNOW, GAVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE LEADERS IN
THIS IN THIS SPACE, WHICH, LIKE
YOU KNOW, GAVE THEM CONFIDENCE
AND GAVE THEM A PLACE TO ENGAGE
WITH EACH OTHER AND BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS. UM AND I AM A
FIRM BELIEVER THAT, UM AT THE
END OF THE DAY, IF YOU HAVE IF
YOU TRUST IF YOU WORK WITH THE
TEAM AND YOU TRUST EACH OTHER
AND YOU HAVE RELATIONSHIPS, YOU
CAN DO ANYTHING TOGETHER, SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I'VE DONE
THAT I CAN THINK OF OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD. THAT WAS A LONG TIME
AGO. I DID THAT. BUT YOU ARE
GOING TO DO IT AGAIN. HE WASN'T
AT èC PF OR AT THE LABOR
AGENCY. THANK YOU, I. I
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSES TO THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR
SENATOR AND MR SECRETARY. I
WOULD LIKE TO LOOK AT SENATOR
AMAN IF SENATOR A THE OTHER
ITEMS FROM ME, ALL RIGHT, BUT
WE'D LIKE TO BETTER DO IS OPEN
IT UP TO ANYONE AND EVERYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF MADAM DEPUTY
SECRETARY. UH, WE'RE GONNA
WELCOME YOU UP TO THE PODIUM. IF
YOU PLEASE SIT YOUR FIRST AND
LAST NAME IN YOUR ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE AFFILIATED WITH. HEY,
GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR
MEMBERS, MEGAN. SO IS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND I'M GLAD WE'VE
ALL BEEN EMOTIONAL ALREADY HERE
TODAY, SO IT WON'T MAKE ME FEEL
BAD FOR READING MY COMMENTS. SO
I DON'T GET WEEPY WE GONNA DO
ABOUT 30 SECONDS, PLEASE? YEP
YEP. SO CPF, AS YOU KNOW,
REPRESENTS ABOUT 35,000 RANK AND
FILE FIREFIGHTERS AND EM S¼
PERSONNEL AND FOR 20 YEARS WE
WERE SO GRATEFUL TO HAVE FERRIS
PART OF OUR TEAM. AND WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT STRONGLY
SUPPORT HER APPOINTMENT AS
DEPUTY SECRETARY AT THE LABOR
AGENCY. MS TSK HAS A LONG AND
ACCOMPLISHED HISTORY IN
ORGANIZED LABOR WITH OVER 20
YEARS SERVING THE MEN AND WOMEN
IN THE FIRE SERVICE AND VARIOUS
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AT èC PF.
THROUGHOUT HER CAREER. SHE'S
SHOWN HER DEDICATION TO
ADVANCING THE GOALS AND GOOD AND
GOOD JOBS, UH, BEING MADE
AVAILABLE TO ALL, WHICH IS
SOMETHING WE KNOW SHE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO IN HER NEW ROLE.
UM HER EXPE EXPERIENCE WITH OUR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AND OUR
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AND
RECRUITING A MORE DIVERSE
POPULATION OF FIREFIGHTERS IN
TWO JUST MAKING THIS WORSE INTO
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN, UM,
TREMENDOUS AND WILL LAST FOR
DECADES. AND OF COURSE, WHAT?
WE'RE SAD TO SEE HER MOVE ON AND
MOVE UP. WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
TIME SHE SPENT JUST BEING A
LEADER AND A MENTOR TO ME AND
ALL OF THE PEOPLE OUT HERE IN
THE AUDIENCE, UM, WITHIN THE
ORGANIZATION AND OUTSIDE THE
ORGANIZATION, AND WE KNOW SHE'LL
BE AN AMAZING ASSET TO THE LABOR
AGENCY. SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU A LOT REALLY WONDERFUL JOB.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GONNA BRING WESLEY UP.
PLEASE. OH HØI. MY NAME IS
SHONDA WESLEY. I AM FORMALLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. I'VE KNOWN FERRIS
FOR OVER 25 YEARS. I HAVE WORKED
FOR HER FOR DECADES NOW IN AND
OUT OF THE UNION, AND I'M GONNA
KEEP IT BRIEF. SO I DON'T MAKE
YOU WEEPY. UM BUT THERE IS VERY
FEW PEOPLE AS TALENTED AS FERRIS
Tð KNO AND I AM VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR HER,
BUT I AM MORE EXCITED ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE HER AS AN
EMPLOYEE. THANK YOU. VERY
GRATEFUL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'D LIKE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE AND SUPPORT
MADAM DEPUTY SECRETARY ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO ADVANCE
IN SUPPORT. PLEASE, SIR. COME ON
FOR THANK YOU. WELCOME AND GOOD
AFTERNOON. THE SHOW FOR ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS. UM ONCE
YOU KNOW ONE, YOU PROBABLY KNOW
MANY OF ALL OF US AND FOUND IN
THE ROOM, SO I THINK IT'S ONLY
FITTING THAT I SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF OUR INDUSTRY BECAUSE WE ARE A
VERY AMALGAMATED GROUP OF
UNIQUELY GIFTED, TALENTED,
SOMETIMES CONFUSING, BUT VERY
CREATIVE INDIVIDUALS. AND FERRIS
HAS HAD THE AUSPICIOUS ROLE OF
CONSTANTLY KEEPING THIS BAND OF
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. SOMETIMES
LIKE HERDING CATS TOGETHER AND
LEADING US TO COMMON GOALS
SOMETIMES AND UNCOMMON TIMES.
AND SO I THINK I SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF ALL OF US WHEN I SAY YOU'VE
DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB BEING A
LEADER OF AMONGST LEADERS, UM TO
QUIET THE BICKERING TO MOVE
AGENDAS FORWARD TO SEE PROBLEMS
COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS IN WHICH
LIKE MINDED INDIVIDUALS
SOMETIMES CAN GET VERY ROOTED IN
ONE PERSPECTIVE, AND SO ON
BEHALF OF THE WORK YOU'VE DONE
FOR èC PF. THAT'S BENEFITED ALL
OF US. I THINK I SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF ALL FIVE OF OUR WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS.
THERE WE GO. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
VERY GRATEFUL. EVERYTHING HERE
TO STATE SMOOTH SO ALL RIGHT.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
AND WE WELCOME EVERYONE TO BE
ABLE TO COME FORWARD AND BE ABLE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF DEPUTY
SECRETARY IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
GOING TO DO A LAST CALL FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT. MR.
SECRETARY, DID YOU WANT IF YOU
WERE TO THANK YOU, UH TO, UH OF
COURSE WE SUPPORT OUR OUR DEPUTY
SECRETARY. UH, FERRIS HAS BEEN
WITH US ABOUT SIX MONTHS, EIGHT
MONTHS SOMEWHERE IN THAT RANGE
AND HAS DONE AN AMAZING JOB TO
DATE. LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE SENATORS, UH, MOVING
THIS FORWARD AND APPRECIATE YOUR
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. KNOX GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE GONNA
DO A LAST CALL. LAST CALL FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT. HERE IN èC  N
N. WE'RE NOW GONNA LOOK FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE TO
THE PODIUM AT THIS TIME, THOUGH
OPPOSITION AND THERE YOU GO.
EXACTLY. YEAH. WE DO A LAST CALL
FOR OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT HERE
AND SEEING NÓ ONE RISE AND OR
SHOUT OUT. WE'RE GONNA BE COMING
ON BACK TO COMMITTEE TO BE TO
SEE IF THERE IS ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE HERE IN SINAN
. WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADMIT,
PLEASE? I, I WOULD BE A POLICE
TO MOVE THE CONFIRMATION OF THE
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SENATOR WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FORM. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE? I GROVE EGM EGM I,
JONES JONES, I LAIRD R LAIRD. I
ON CALL. WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT
ON CALL, MADAM. DEPUTY SECRETARY
. THANK YOU. WONDERFUL TO SEE
YOU. THANK YOU. I WILL BE
HEADING TO THE FLOOR. SO, YEAH,
YOU CAN ALL SLAP. THERE WE GO.
IT'S ALL GOOD. THANK YOU. AND AS
THE SECOND BIG THANK YOU TO
SHARON AND JOHANNA AND DS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE. IT
IS AN HONOR THAT YOU ARE HERE.
AND WHY DON'T WE DO SOME
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE? IF YOU LIKE
TO BRING YOUR FAMILY UP AND TAKE
A PICTURE, PLEASE. UH, COME ON,
FORWARD. UH, LET'S BRING MOM UP,
AND WE'LL ALSO BRING DRI AND
JOHAN. IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE A PICTURE, PLEASE. WE'RE
GOING TO CALL A TWO MINUTE
RECESS. TWO MINUTE RECESS,
PLEASE. WE HAVE ON CALL SENATOR
EDMAN AND I.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
COMMITTEE. WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO IS WE'RE GOING TO START FROM
THE TOP WORK OUR WAY DOWN. THEN
WE'LL WRAP IT UP HERE FOR DAY
FOR TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH ITEM ONE A AND B MY BELIEF,
MADAM SECRETARY. WE'RE GOING TO
ADD, UM SENATOR EDMAN ONTO ONE A
ONE B. MADAM SECRETARY. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. I 52050 VOTE. THOSE TWO
ARE OUT AND WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE
THE ROLL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ONE èC AM ERICSON. I BELIEVE
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
CAPTURE VOTES FROM SENATOR
AIKMAN, SENATOR JONES AND
SENATOR GROVE. MADAM SECRETARY,
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS? GROVE GROVE? I EGM EGM.
I JONES JONES. I 5 TO 0. LOOK AT
THAT 5 TO 0. THAT ITEM IS OUT
AND WE ARE GOING TO CLOSE THE
ROLL. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO ITEM Dð MAD DEPUTY
SECRETARY. WE NEED TO CAPTURE
THE VOTE OF SENATOR GROVE. MADAM
VICE CHAIR. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL GROVE
GROVE I FIVE TO 05 TO ZERO VOTE.
LOOK AT THAT. EVERYBODY. THAT
ITEM IS OUT AND WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE THE ROLL. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, THIS CONCLUDES
TODAY'S AGENDA. THANK YOU ALL
FOR EACH OF YOU WHO PARTICIPATED
IN FOR THEIR PATIENTS.
COOPERATIONS WE'RE GOING TO BE
CALLING THIS MEETING ADJOURNED.